Well, you guys know we love Airbnb. I also just did a ladies' birthday trip. It was my friend's 50th birthday. All of us gals drove up the coast. It was so fun. We had the kitchen to hang out in, but then we all had our own space because, you know, we love each other, but I mean, I kind of want my own space at night. You know what I'm saying. We love the privacy. They're always in such great locations where you can really get to know the town you're in. And there's some real hidden gyms out there. These little pockets and neighbors, that you might not see if you stayed at a hotel. Listen, I could go on and on about Airbnb because I love it. It's a great way to travel with friends and family. And you know, your home might be perfect for Airbnb. If you frequently travel or have extra space, maybe you go out of town at the same time every year for a family trip, your home could earn you money while you're away. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca.ca.com. Hey, office ladies fans, Jenna and Angela here with some exciting news. Our holiday merch is here, and we are so tickled.
Well, you guys know we love Airbnb. I also just did a ladies' birthday trip. It was my friend's 50th birthday. All of us gals drove up the coast. It was so fun. We had the kitchen to hang out in, but then we all had our own space because, you know, we love each other, but I mean, I kind of want my own space at night. You know what I'm saying. We love the privacy. They're always in such great locations where you can really get to know the town you're in. And there's some real hidden gyms out there. These little pockets and neighbors, that you might not see if you stayed at a hotel. Listen, I could go on and on about Airbnb because I love it. It's a great way to travel with friends and family. And you know, your home might be perfect for Airbnb. If you frequently travel or have extra space, maybe you go out of town at the same time every year for a family trip, your home could earn you money while you're away. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca.ca.com. Hey, office ladies fans, Jenna and Angela here with some exciting news. Our holiday merch is here, and we are so tickled.|||Well, you guys know we love Airbnb. I also just did a ladies' birthday trip. It was my friend's 50th birthday. All of us gals drove up the coast. It was so fun. We had the kitchen to hang out in, but then we all had our own space because, you know, we love each other, but I mean, I kind of want my own space at night. You know what I'm saying. We love the privacy. They're always in such great locations where you can really get to know the town you're in. And there's some real hidden gyms out there. These little pockets and neighbors, that you might not see if you stayed at a hotel. Listen, I could go on and on about Airbnb because I love it. It's a great way to travel with friends and family. And you know, your home might be perfect for Airbnb. If you frequently travel or have extra space, maybe you go out of town at the same time every year for a family trip, your home could earn you money while you're away. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca.ca.com. Hey, office ladies fans, Jenna and Angela here with some exciting news. Our holiday merch is here, and we are so tickled.
You know Angela spearheads our merch, and she has once again designed some adorable stuff. We've got brand new party planning committee sweatshirts, so you can plan your next holiday party in true Scranton style. Yes, and they're super comfy. And don't forget, your very own office ladies ornament is perfect for your tree or your desk or a gift for all your friends and family. Angela pulled some very funny office quotes for the ornaments. Well, there were a lot to choose from. But listen, hurry, because these holiday goodies are only available from November 5th through 12th.
You know Angela spearheads our merch, and she has once again designed some adorable stuff. We've got brand new party planning committee sweatshirts, so you can plan your next holiday party in true Scranton style. Yes, and they're super comfy. And don't forget, your very own office ladies ornament is perfect for your tree or your desk or a gift for all your friends and family. Angela pulled some very funny office quotes for the ornaments. Well, there were a lot to choose from. But listen, hurry, because these holiday goodies are only available from November 5th through 12th.|||You know Angela spearheads our merch, and she has once again designed some adorable stuff. We've got brand new party planning committee sweatshirts, so you can plan your next holiday party in true Scranton style. Yes, and they're super comfy. And don't forget, your very own office ladies ornament is perfect for your tree or your desk or a gift for all your friends and family. Angela pulled some very funny office quotes for the ornaments. Well, there were a lot to choose from. But listen, hurry, because these holiday goodies are only available from November 5th through 12th.
And some of our selected items from our last merch pop-up are still available until they sell out. So hurry and go check it out. Head to shopofficeladies.com and grab yours before they're gone. Happy holidays. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
And some of our selected items from our last merch pop-up are still available until they sell out. So hurry and go check it out. Head to shopofficeladies.com and grab yours before they're gone. Happy holidays. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews|||And some of our selected items from our last merch pop-up are still available until they sell out. So hurry and go check it out. Head to shopofficeladies.com and grab yours before they're gone. Happy holidays. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hey there. I'm very excited about today's episode. Same lady. We have been wanting to have this guest. on for a long time. And it finally happened. Jenna, you want to tell everyone who we're talking to
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hey there. I'm very excited about today's episode. Same lady. We have been wanting to have this guest. on for a long time. And it finally happened. Jenna, you want to tell everyone who we're talking to|||behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hey there. I'm very excited about today's episode. Same lady. We have been wanting to have this guest. on for a long time. And it finally happened. Jenna, you want to tell everyone who we're talking to
today? Well, yes, we are talking with Tig Nataro. Remember when we broke down Test the Store in season eight, we were not able to speak with her. And we got a lot of mail. I want to read you some. Kimberly T. from Utah said, please, please interview Tig Nataro for this episode. Your podcast and hers are two of my favorites, and I'm dying for a crossover. And Abigail D from Boston said, special guest star alert. I absolutely love the sitcom queen Tignitaro as Tiffany's mom. She's also been in episodes of New Girl, Instant Family, Community, and Fresh Off the Boat, such a talented stand-up comedian, and I was just so tickled to see her do such a
today? Well, yes, we are talking with Tig Nataro. Remember when we broke down Test the Store in season eight, we were not able to speak with her. And we got a lot of mail. I want to read you some. Kimberly T. from Utah said, please, please interview Tig Nataro for this episode. Your podcast and hers are two of my favorites, and I'm dying for a crossover. And Abigail D from Boston said, special guest star alert. I absolutely love the sitcom queen Tignitaro as Tiffany's mom. She's also been in episodes of New Girl, Instant Family, Community, and Fresh Off the Boat, such a talented stand-up comedian, and I was just so tickled to see her do such a|||today? Well, yes, we are talking with Tig Nataro. Remember when we broke down Test the Store in season eight, we were not able to speak with her. And we got a lot of mail. I want to read you some. Kimberly T. from Utah said, please, please interview Tig Nataro for this episode. Your podcast and hers are two of my favorites, and I'm dying for a crossover. And Abigail D from Boston said, special guest star alert. I absolutely love the sitcom queen Tignitaro as Tiffany's mom. She's also been in episodes of New Girl, Instant Family, Community, and Fresh Off the Boat, such a talented stand-up comedian, and I was just so tickled to see her do such a
great job on this show. Way to go, TIG. Well, we were so excited when TIG was on set when we filmed this. We were thrilled she was going to be part of the office. We were big fans. We're still big fans. And as Abigail said, TIG is a stand-up comedian. She's an actress, a writer, producer, podcaster.
great job on this show. Way to go, TIG. Well, we were so excited when TIG was on set when we filmed this. We were thrilled she was going to be part of the office. We were big fans. We're still big fans. And as Abigail said, TIG is a stand-up comedian. She's an actress, a writer, producer, podcaster.|||great job on this show. Way to go, TIG. Well, we were so excited when TIG was on set when we filmed this. We were thrilled she was going to be part of the office. We were big fans. We're still big fans. And as Abigail said, TIG is a stand-up comedian. She's an actress, a writer, producer, podcaster.
She's been nominated for a Grammy Award for her album Live. And her special Boyish Girl Interrupted was nominated for an Emmy Award and a Grammy. She has written several stand-up specials is a favorite on late-night talk shows. And you can see her in many television shows and film. Most recently, you can catch her on her new comedy special. Hello Again. That was directed by her wife, Stephanie Allen. And she's on the morning show, Star Trek Discovery, and she is filming Star Trek Starfleet Academy series now.
She's been nominated for a Grammy Award for her album Live. And her special Boyish Girl Interrupted was nominated for an Emmy Award and a Grammy. She has written several stand-up specials is a favorite on late-night talk shows. And you can see her in many television shows and film. Most recently, you can catch her on her new comedy special. Hello Again. That was directed by her wife, Stephanie Allen. And she's on the morning show, Star Trek Discovery, and she is filming Star Trek Starfleet Academy series now.|||She's been nominated for a Grammy Award for her album Live. And her special Boyish Girl Interrupted was nominated for an Emmy Award and a Grammy. She has written several stand-up specials is a favorite on late-night talk shows. And you can see her in many television shows and film. Most recently, you can catch her on her new comedy special. Hello Again. That was directed by her wife, Stephanie Allen. And she's on the morning show, Star Trek Discovery, and she is filming Star Trek Starfleet Academy series now.
You asked her a lot about it, Ange. Angela really geeked out on the... I mean, this is a huge, huge show to be a part of. It's a big deal. And we also got a lot of mail from you all about it. Yeah. She was also in Justin Noble. and Mindy Kaling's show Sex Lives of College Girls on Netflix.
You asked her a lot about it, Ange. Angela really geeked out on the... I mean, this is a huge, huge show to be a part of. It's a big deal. And we also got a lot of mail from you all about it. Yeah. She was also in Justin Noble. and Mindy Kaling's show Sex Lives of College Girls on Netflix.|||You asked her a lot about it, Ange. Angela really geeked out on the... I mean, this is a huge, huge show to be a part of. It's a big deal. And we also got a lot of mail from you all about it. Yeah. She was also in Justin Noble. and Mindy Kaling's show Sex Lives of College Girls on Netflix.
Well, Mindy is a very big fan of Tig. We shared when we broke down Test the Store that it was Mindy who requested Tig for the role of Tiffany's mom. Yeah. And I went back and rewatch Test the Store's superfan episode on Peacock. Tick's scene has an extra couplet of dialogue, and it cracked me up. I thought we should hear it. Now, if your attacker is willing to defile a corpse, you better stop playing dead right away
Well, Mindy is a very big fan of Tig. We shared when we broke down Test the Store that it was Mindy who requested Tig for the role of Tiffany's mom. Yeah. And I went back and rewatch Test the Store's superfan episode on Peacock. Tick's scene has an extra couplet of dialogue, and it cracked me up. I thought we should hear it. Now, if your attacker is willing to defile a corpse, you better stop playing dead right away|||Well, Mindy is a very big fan of Tig. We shared when we broke down Test the Store that it was Mindy who requested Tig for the role of Tiffany's mom. Yeah. And I went back and rewatch Test the Store's superfan episode on Peacock. Tick's scene has an extra couplet of dialogue, and it cracked me up. I thought we should hear it. Now, if your attacker is willing to defile a corpse, you better stop playing dead right away
And just make it known that you're alive. Forgive me for interrupting. I believe my daughter had an altercation with somebody here. Some fancy gentlemen with a squeaky voice. I think you guys might have the wrong office. That's him. The guy I hit. What?
And just make it known that you're alive. Forgive me for interrupting. I believe my daughter had an altercation with somebody here. Some fancy gentlemen with a squeaky voice. I think you guys might have the wrong office. That's him. The guy I hit. What?|||And just make it known that you're alive. Forgive me for interrupting. I believe my daughter had an altercation with somebody here. Some fancy gentlemen with a squeaky voice. I think you guys might have the wrong office. That's him. The guy I hit. What?
What? You've got to be kidding me. Poor Andy. First you got beat up by a gang, and now she kicks your ass. No, Kevin. What about the lady you hit with a pine cone? There, that chubby one. I just had a baby.
What? You've got to be kidding me. Poor Andy. First you got beat up by a gang, and now she kicks your ass. No, Kevin. What about the lady you hit with a pine cone? There, that chubby one. I just had a baby.|||What? You've got to be kidding me. Poor Andy. First you got beat up by a gang, and now she kicks your ass. No, Kevin. What about the lady you hit with a pine cone? There, that chubby one. I just had a baby.
Yesterday. Wow. Apologize. Sorry I kicked your ass in front of your thin girlfriend. How about we wait till next year after you have your kid? You know what, Tiffy's going to college. Listen, I don't know what you guys are talking about, but I guess I'll just accept your apology so we can get on with our day. Sorry I punched you.
Yesterday. Wow. Apologize. Sorry I kicked your ass in front of your thin girlfriend. How about we wait till next year after you have your kid? You know what, Tiffy's going to college. Listen, I don't know what you guys are talking about, but I guess I'll just accept your apology so we can get on with our day. Sorry I punched you.|||Yesterday. Wow. Apologize. Sorry I kicked your ass in front of your thin girlfriend. How about we wait till next year after you have your kid? You know what, Tiffy's going to college. Listen, I don't know what you guys are talking about, but I guess I'll just accept your apology so we can get on with our day. Sorry I punched you.
And I promise I'll take it off Facebook. It's on Facebook. There we go. God bless. A friend of mine uses your paper. is your paper. You do good work. Bye-bye. Bye. I'm so glad you played that, Angela, because, well, you'll hear in the interview, but TIG has a very unique point of view of shooting that scene that is so funny.
And I promise I'll take it off Facebook. It's on Facebook. There we go. God bless. A friend of mine uses your paper. is your paper. You do good work. Bye-bye. Bye. I'm so glad you played that, Angela, because, well, you'll hear in the interview, but TIG has a very unique point of view of shooting that scene that is so funny.|||And I promise I'll take it off Facebook. It's on Facebook. There we go. God bless. A friend of mine uses your paper. is your paper. You do good work. Bye-bye. Bye. I'm so glad you played that, Angela, because, well, you'll hear in the interview, but TIG has a very unique point of view of shooting that scene that is so funny.
Yes, her memory of filming it is hilarious, and it's a piece of information neither of us knew. She's never shared it before. But I love the extra couplet of dialogue about the fact that her daughter had uploaded it to Facebook. Yes. Further humiliation for Andy. Yes. Well, everyone, why don't we take a break? Why wait any longer?
Yes, her memory of filming it is hilarious, and it's a piece of information neither of us knew. She's never shared it before. But I love the extra couplet of dialogue about the fact that her daughter had uploaded it to Facebook. Yes. Further humiliation for Andy. Yes. Well, everyone, why don't we take a break? Why wait any longer?|||Yes, her memory of filming it is hilarious, and it's a piece of information neither of us knew. She's never shared it before. But I love the extra couplet of dialogue about the fact that her daughter had uploaded it to Facebook. Yes. Further humiliation for Andy. Yes. Well, everyone, why don't we take a break? Why wait any longer?
And then when we come back, it's our interview with Tignitaro. Yeah, let's do it. I want you to take a second and become aware of the smell around you. Does it smell like kind of like nothing? Do you smell something? Scent has this amazing power to influence the energy of a space or express the individuality of a space. It can enhance your mood and your feelings.
And then when we come back, it's our interview with Tignitaro. Yeah, let's do it. I want you to take a second and become aware of the smell around you. Does it smell like kind of like nothing? Do you smell something? Scent has this amazing power to influence the energy of a space or express the individuality of a space. It can enhance your mood and your feelings.|||And then when we come back, it's our interview with Tignitaro. Yeah, let's do it. I want you to take a second and become aware of the smell around you. Does it smell like kind of like nothing? Do you smell something? Scent has this amazing power to influence the energy of a space or express the individuality of a space. It can enhance your mood and your feelings.
And Pura wants to tap into that positivity of scent. Pura makes the coolest diffusers, mini diffusers, larger diffusers, and they have a gazillion cents available. So if you want to walk into your bathroom and have it smell like a tropical vacation, you can have that. If you want to walk into your kitchen and have it smell like the holidays or like fresh baked cookies. And right now, Pura is having a special promo where you get a free Pura set when you subscribe. Subscribe to a festive scent now and easily swap it later. This exclusive deal won't last, so shop now at pura.com. What's up, guys? It's Candace Dillard Bassett, former Real Housewife of Potomac.
And Pura wants to tap into that positivity of scent. Pura makes the coolest diffusers, mini diffusers, larger diffusers, and they have a gazillion cents available. So if you want to walk into your bathroom and have it smell like a tropical vacation, you can have that. If you want to walk into your kitchen and have it smell like the holidays or like fresh baked cookies. And right now, Pura is having a special promo where you get a free Pura set when you subscribe. Subscribe to a festive scent now and easily swap it later. This exclusive deal won't last, so shop now at pura.com. What's up, guys? It's Candace Dillard Bassett, former Real Housewife of Potomac.|||And Pura wants to tap into that positivity of scent. Pura makes the coolest diffusers, mini diffusers, larger diffusers, and they have a gazillion cents available. So if you want to walk into your bathroom and have it smell like a tropical vacation, you can have that. If you want to walk into your kitchen and have it smell like the holidays or like fresh baked cookies. And right now, Pura is having a special promo where you get a free Pura set when you subscribe. Subscribe to a festive scent now and easily swap it later. This exclusive deal won't last, so shop now at pura.com. What's up, guys? It's Candace Dillard Bassett, former Real Housewife of Potomac.
And I'm Michael Arsino, author of The New York Times Bestseller, I Can't Date Jesus. And this is Undomesticated. The podcast, where we aren't just saying the quiet parts out loud, we're putting it all on the kitchen table and inviting you to the function. If you're ready for some bold takes and a little bit of chaos, welcome to Undomesticated. Follow and listen to Undomesticated, available wherever you get your podcasts. Hello there. Are you talking to me? We are.
And I'm Michael Arsino, author of The New York Times Bestseller, I Can't Date Jesus. And this is Undomesticated. The podcast, where we aren't just saying the quiet parts out loud, we're putting it all on the kitchen table and inviting you to the function. If you're ready for some bold takes and a little bit of chaos, welcome to Undomesticated. Follow and listen to Undomesticated, available wherever you get your podcasts. Hello there. Are you talking to me? We are.|||And I'm Michael Arsino, author of The New York Times Bestseller, I Can't Date Jesus. And this is Undomesticated. The podcast, where we aren't just saying the quiet parts out loud, we're putting it all on the kitchen table and inviting you to the function. If you're ready for some bold takes and a little bit of chaos, welcome to Undomesticated. Follow and listen to Undomesticated, available wherever you get your podcasts. Hello there. Are you talking to me? We are.
Oh, okay. I wasn't sure if, like, you needed to do a little something and then talk to me and then. Oh, we'll do that. Okay. But we don't make you sit through it. Okay. We're like, hey, we've got a great episode for you today. Yeah.
Oh, okay. I wasn't sure if, like, you needed to do a little something and then talk to me and then. Oh, we'll do that. Okay. But we don't make you sit through it. Okay. We're like, hey, we've got a great episode for you today. Yeah.|||Oh, okay. I wasn't sure if, like, you needed to do a little something and then talk to me and then. Oh, we'll do that. Okay. But we don't make you sit through it. Okay. We're like, hey, we've got a great episode for you today. Yeah.
TIG is here. We did that already. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. But we're super excited to see you. I am very excited to be here. here. TIG, we asked our listeners to send in questions for you, and we're going to ask you
TIG is here. We did that already. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. But we're super excited to see you. I am very excited to be here. here. TIG, we asked our listeners to send in questions for you, and we're going to ask you|||TIG is here. We did that already. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. But we're super excited to see you. I am very excited to be here. here. TIG, we asked our listeners to send in questions for you, and we're going to ask you
some of their questions. Okay. But I have to share that when I was going through the digital mailbag, I have not forever in the five years we've been doing this, seen the kind of letters that you inspired from people. And we've talked to a lot of people, TIG, have you? This isn't episode one. It's our news spin-off podcast. We got a lot of not questions for you, just letters from people expressing their enthusiasm for you, and I'm going to read you one. That's so nice. I thought it would be a good way to kick things off. I hope it's a long letter. It's not. It's a short one. Okay. But it's great. I'll still hear it. It's from Rebecca D in Edinburgh. Hi, Rebecca. Rebecca said, Tigg, why are you so amazing?
some of their questions. Okay. But I have to share that when I was going through the digital mailbag, I have not forever in the five years we've been doing this, seen the kind of letters that you inspired from people. And we've talked to a lot of people, TIG, have you? This isn't episode one. It's our news spin-off podcast. We got a lot of not questions for you, just letters from people expressing their enthusiasm for you, and I'm going to read you one. That's so nice. I thought it would be a good way to kick things off. I hope it's a long letter. It's not. It's a short one. Okay. But it's great. I'll still hear it. It's from Rebecca D in Edinburgh. Hi, Rebecca. Rebecca said, Tigg, why are you so amazing?|||some of their questions. Okay. But I have to share that when I was going through the digital mailbag, I have not forever in the five years we've been doing this, seen the kind of letters that you inspired from people. And we've talked to a lot of people, TIG, have you? This isn't episode one. It's our news spin-off podcast. We got a lot of not questions for you, just letters from people expressing their enthusiasm for you, and I'm going to read you one. That's so nice. I thought it would be a good way to kick things off. I hope it's a long letter. It's not. It's a short one. Okay. But it's great. I'll still hear it. It's from Rebecca D in Edinburgh. Hi, Rebecca. Rebecca said, Tigg, why are you so amazing?
How do I become more like you, and where do I sign up to be your friend? I don't have any questions. I'm just looking forward to hearing y'all chat also f cancer that is very nice that letter we got over and over again with slight differences but but it was rebecca every time it was Rebecca you are tricky I'm like Rebecca D from Edinburgh again but with a different accent in her writing spelled Rebecca different a few different ways you are beloved oh that is kind that's It's very nice. Thank you for embarrassing me. I know. How do you do with like praise like that? Because I always like say something like, you're like, oh, your hair looks nice. I'm like, I didn't wash it. Yeah. Like I can't. Or, oh, nice Christmas pajamas. Oh, they're clean, I think. I think.
How do I become more like you, and where do I sign up to be your friend? I don't have any questions. I'm just looking forward to hearing y'all chat also f cancer that is very nice that letter we got over and over again with slight differences but but it was rebecca every time it was Rebecca you are tricky I'm like Rebecca D from Edinburgh again but with a different accent in her writing spelled Rebecca different a few different ways you are beloved oh that is kind that's It's very nice. Thank you for embarrassing me. I know. How do you do with like praise like that? Because I always like say something like, you're like, oh, your hair looks nice. I'm like, I didn't wash it. Yeah. Like I can't. Or, oh, nice Christmas pajamas. Oh, they're clean, I think. I think.|||How do I become more like you, and where do I sign up to be your friend? I don't have any questions. I'm just looking forward to hearing y'all chat also f cancer that is very nice that letter we got over and over again with slight differences but but it was rebecca every time it was Rebecca you are tricky I'm like Rebecca D from Edinburgh again but with a different accent in her writing spelled Rebecca different a few different ways you are beloved oh that is kind that's It's very nice. Thank you for embarrassing me. I know. How do you do with like praise like that? Because I always like say something like, you're like, oh, your hair looks nice. I'm like, I didn't wash it. Yeah. Like I can't. Or, oh, nice Christmas pajamas. Oh, they're clean, I think. I think.
That's from earlier off my convo. You guys, I dropped things off to the school this morning in Christmas pajamas. Yes. Don't judge me. And I tried to get to this recording today and circled the building many times and drove everybody behind me crazy. But we're here. We're here. And I drop swimsuits off for my sons today. This is what you do. That's what I do. I know. Yeah. Well, we are so happy to have you here. And, you know, we broke down this episode that you're on, test the store during the strike. And we couldn't talk to you then because, you know, we were following the rules and whatnot. But we always start our interviews and we ask people, how did you get your job on the office? Well, I went in an audition and I'm not a big auditioner, not because I am a
That's from earlier off my convo. You guys, I dropped things off to the school this morning in Christmas pajamas. Yes. Don't judge me. And I tried to get to this recording today and circled the building many times and drove everybody behind me crazy. But we're here. We're here. And I drop swimsuits off for my sons today. This is what you do. That's what I do. I know. Yeah. Well, we are so happy to have you here. And, you know, we broke down this episode that you're on, test the store during the strike. And we couldn't talk to you then because, you know, we were following the rules and whatnot. But we always start our interviews and we ask people, how did you get your job on the office? Well, I went in an audition and I'm not a big auditioner, not because I am a|||That's from earlier off my convo. You guys, I dropped things off to the school this morning in Christmas pajamas. Yes. Don't judge me. And I tried to get to this recording today and circled the building many times and drove everybody behind me crazy. But we're here. We're here. And I drop swimsuits off for my sons today. This is what you do. That's what I do. I know. Yeah. Well, we are so happy to have you here. And, you know, we broke down this episode that you're on, test the store during the strike. And we couldn't talk to you then because, you know, we were following the rules and whatnot. But we always start our interviews and we ask people, how did you get your job on the office? Well, I went in an audition and I'm not a big auditioner, not because I am a
fancy person. It is really the opposite because I'm not good at auditioning and I don't really identify, or I haven't. I'm starting more so identifying with acting, but I'm a stand-up comedian who have, you know, I have friends that have TV shows and I ended up on them. And then it just kind of has kept happening. And I'm almost, I'm like 25 years into acting. And I still tell people, I'm like, oh, no, I'm not an actor. I'm a stand-up comedian. And so I did happen to audition for that because it's like, oh, it's the office.
fancy person. It is really the opposite because I'm not good at auditioning and I don't really identify, or I haven't. I'm starting more so identifying with acting, but I'm a stand-up comedian who have, you know, I have friends that have TV shows and I ended up on them. And then it just kind of has kept happening. And I'm almost, I'm like 25 years into acting. And I still tell people, I'm like, oh, no, I'm not an actor. I'm a stand-up comedian. And so I did happen to audition for that because it's like, oh, it's the office.|||fancy person. It is really the opposite because I'm not good at auditioning and I don't really identify, or I haven't. I'm starting more so identifying with acting, but I'm a stand-up comedian who have, you know, I have friends that have TV shows and I ended up on them. And then it just kind of has kept happening. And I'm almost, I'm like 25 years into acting. And I still tell people, I'm like, oh, no, I'm not an actor. I'm a stand-up comedian. And so I did happen to audition for that because it's like, oh, it's the office.
I'm going to go give that a whirl. And then I got it. Which is not, it's, I usually get a job if I don't audition. Because I'm typically taking space or taking a cop suit. Right, yeah. You know, so that's why I don't audition. I like thinking of you like that now. I'm like, tigs in the car.
I'm going to go give that a whirl. And then I got it. Which is not, it's, I usually get a job if I don't audition. Because I'm typically taking space or taking a cop suit. Right, yeah. You know, so that's why I don't audition. I like thinking of you like that now. I'm like, tigs in the car.|||I'm going to go give that a whirl. And then I got it. Which is not, it's, I usually get a job if I don't audition. Because I'm typically taking space or taking a cop suit. Right, yeah. You know, so that's why I don't audition. I like thinking of you like that now. I'm like, tigs in the car.
Yeah, that's right. Circling the building. Yes. Well, we know that Mindy is a huge fan of yours. Well, I remember afterwards Mindy was saying, oh, when you came in to audition, I was like, oh, we got a higher TIG. And so I don't even know if my audition really mattered. So maybe it was because Mindy liked me. What was your experience like when you came to set that?
Yeah, that's right. Circling the building. Yes. Well, we know that Mindy is a huge fan of yours. Well, I remember afterwards Mindy was saying, oh, when you came in to audition, I was like, oh, we got a higher TIG. And so I don't even know if my audition really mattered. So maybe it was because Mindy liked me. What was your experience like when you came to set that?|||Yeah, that's right. Circling the building. Yes. Well, we know that Mindy is a huge fan of yours. Well, I remember afterwards Mindy was saying, oh, when you came in to audition, I was like, oh, we got a higher TIG. And so I don't even know if my audition really mattered. So maybe it was because Mindy liked me. What was your experience like when you came to set that?
because this was early in your acting career. Oh, yes. You've done Sarah Silverman, which is a little bit more sketch comedy, I guess. How was this? Because you were in the conference room with everybody, staring at you. I was. And I told you before we started that I wanted to apologize ahead of time for my experience on the office. Okay.
because this was early in your acting career. Oh, yes. You've done Sarah Silverman, which is a little bit more sketch comedy, I guess. How was this? Because you were in the conference room with everybody, staring at you. I was. And I told you before we started that I wanted to apologize ahead of time for my experience on the office. Okay.|||because this was early in your acting career. Oh, yes. You've done Sarah Silverman, which is a little bit more sketch comedy, I guess. How was this? Because you were in the conference room with everybody, staring at you. I was. And I told you before we started that I wanted to apologize ahead of time for my experience on the office. Okay.
It was everybody was very nice to me. Okay. This was all my doing. this goes back to me, not really identifying with being an actor. And I also want to back up and explain something about myself that people always kind of roll their eyes and go, it can't, not really, but really, I don't watch, I don't follow TV and film, okay? I follow music and documentaries. We've listened to your podcast, Handsome, which is hilarious.
It was everybody was very nice to me. Okay. This was all my doing. this goes back to me, not really identifying with being an actor. And I also want to back up and explain something about myself that people always kind of roll their eyes and go, it can't, not really, but really, I don't watch, I don't follow TV and film, okay? I follow music and documentaries. We've listened to your podcast, Handsome, which is hilarious.|||It was everybody was very nice to me. Okay. This was all my doing. this goes back to me, not really identifying with being an actor. And I also want to back up and explain something about myself that people always kind of roll their eyes and go, it can't, not really, but really, I don't watch, I don't follow TV and film, okay? I follow music and documentaries. We've listened to your podcast, Handsome, which is hilarious.
And so we know this about you. It is very true. So, like, I mean, you didn't know who Selena Gomez was. Yes. I said, Lena? Yeah, I know. And it's true. Yeah.
And so we know this about you. It is very true. So, like, I mean, you didn't know who Selena Gomez was. Yes. I said, Lena? Yeah, I know. And it's true. Yeah.|||And so we know this about you. It is very true. So, like, I mean, you didn't know who Selena Gomez was. Yes. I said, Lena? Yeah, I know. And it's true. Yeah.
Like, even the other, I produced this documentary where my friend who is, like, a hardcore, like, hairy armpit activist in the mountains of Colorado, didn't know, acknowledged on the documentary that they didn't know who Mary Kate and Ashley Olson were. And Stephanie was like, there's no. My wife, Stephanie said, there's no. there's no way Andrea doesn't know. And I said, Andrea is like doing massive activism, living in the mountains. And I'm sure they really don't know who Mary Kate and Olson is. That's what I said. Mary Kate and Olson.
Like, even the other, I produced this documentary where my friend who is, like, a hardcore, like, hairy armpit activist in the mountains of Colorado, didn't know, acknowledged on the documentary that they didn't know who Mary Kate and Ashley Olson were. And Stephanie was like, there's no. My wife, Stephanie said, there's no. there's no way Andrea doesn't know. And I said, Andrea is like doing massive activism, living in the mountains. And I'm sure they really don't know who Mary Kate and Olson is. That's what I said. Mary Kate and Olson.|||Like, even the other, I produced this documentary where my friend who is, like, a hardcore, like, hairy armpit activist in the mountains of Colorado, didn't know, acknowledged on the documentary that they didn't know who Mary Kate and Ashley Olson were. And Stephanie was like, there's no. My wife, Stephanie said, there's no. there's no way Andrea doesn't know. And I said, Andrea is like doing massive activism, living in the mountains. And I'm sure they really don't know who Mary Kate and Olson is. That's what I said. Mary Kate and Olson.
And the 70 was like, what did you just say? And I was like, what did I say? And she said, you said, Mary Kate and Olson. And I was like, okay, so if I said that and I work in Hollywood, chances are my friend in the mountains does not know who Mary Kate Nolson are. So anyway, I just wanted to give that backstory. Okay. And now comes the embarrassing, mortifying part. Okay. You're on set. I'm like, I've learned my lines, which is a whole task for me. I mean, getting my lines down, I'm in a panic and always. I go on to set and I hadn't ever seen the office, okay? Okay. And now I'm
And the 70 was like, what did you just say? And I was like, what did I say? And she said, you said, Mary Kate and Olson. And I was like, okay, so if I said that and I work in Hollywood, chances are my friend in the mountains does not know who Mary Kate Nolson are. So anyway, I just wanted to give that backstory. Okay. And now comes the embarrassing, mortifying part. Okay. You're on set. I'm like, I've learned my lines, which is a whole task for me. I mean, getting my lines down, I'm in a panic and always. I go on to set and I hadn't ever seen the office, okay? Okay. And now I'm|||And the 70 was like, what did you just say? And I was like, what did I say? And she said, you said, Mary Kate and Olson. And I was like, okay, so if I said that and I work in Hollywood, chances are my friend in the mountains does not know who Mary Kate Nolson are. So anyway, I just wanted to give that backstory. Okay. And now comes the embarrassing, mortifying part. Okay. You're on set. I'm like, I've learned my lines, which is a whole task for me. I mean, getting my lines down, I'm in a panic and always. I go on to set and I hadn't ever seen the office, okay? Okay. And now I'm
I'm on set filming the office. And I'm, as you said, in the conference room with everybody, I realized I didn't know who the characters were. So I didn't know who to direct the lines to. You didn't know who Pam was. I didn't know who anybody was. And it didn't dawn on me while I was learning the lines. And then when I walk in and I see everybody and I had to see Andy with the Shiner. I see everybody, and I'm like, I don't know who.
I'm on set filming the office. And I'm, as you said, in the conference room with everybody, I realized I didn't know who the characters were. So I didn't know who to direct the lines to. You didn't know who Pam was. I didn't know who anybody was. And it didn't dawn on me while I was learning the lines. And then when I walk in and I see everybody and I had to see Andy with the Shiner. I see everybody, and I'm like, I don't know who.|||I'm on set filming the office. And I'm, as you said, in the conference room with everybody, I realized I didn't know who the characters were. So I didn't know who to direct the lines to. You didn't know who Pam was. I didn't know who anybody was. And it didn't dawn on me while I was learning the lines. And then when I walk in and I see everybody and I had to see Andy with the Shiner. I see everybody, and I'm like, I don't know who.
And I was directing my lines in the wrong direction, and I was corrected. And they're like, you're looking at, and I was like, oh, my God, get me out of this situation. You know what? You had so many options. I have people. There's so many people. And I was just going on a wild, like, like, looking at it. You know what?
And I was directing my lines in the wrong direction, and I was corrected. And they're like, you're looking at, and I was like, oh, my God, get me out of this situation. You know what? You had so many options. I have people. There's so many people. And I was just going on a wild, like, like, looking at it. You know what?|||And I was directing my lines in the wrong direction, and I was corrected. And they're like, you're looking at, and I was like, oh, my God, get me out of this situation. You know what? You had so many options. I have people. There's so many people. And I was just going on a wild, like, like, looking at it. You know what?
You know what is so funny? You remember this? Well, now I will say this. I watched that there's the super fan version of it now on Peacock, right? And it's pretty much the same as the original broadcast. There's one or two more couplets of dialogue. But now that you said it, because it's very fresh in my mind, at the end, you look out at everyone and you look at people and you go,
You know what is so funny? You remember this? Well, now I will say this. I watched that there's the super fan version of it now on Peacock, right? And it's pretty much the same as the original broadcast. There's one or two more couplets of dialogue. But now that you said it, because it's very fresh in my mind, at the end, you look out at everyone and you look at people and you go,|||You know what is so funny? You remember this? Well, now I will say this. I watched that there's the super fan version of it now on Peacock, right? And it's pretty much the same as the original broadcast. There's one or two more couplets of dialogue. But now that you said it, because it's very fresh in my mind, at the end, you look out at everyone and you look at people and you go,
you make good paper here. And like, you're looking at. at the accountant and like, you're sort of, your, your gaze is kind of like dear in headlights. Oh, it was. Like, because you have no idea who's making the paper. And I went over this with my wife. I, uh, when I was getting ready for bed last night, I said, Stephanie, I'm doing, uh, office ladies.
you make good paper here. And like, you're looking at. at the accountant and like, you're sort of, your, your gaze is kind of like dear in headlights. Oh, it was. Like, because you have no idea who's making the paper. And I went over this with my wife. I, uh, when I was getting ready for bed last night, I said, Stephanie, I'm doing, uh, office ladies.|||you make good paper here. And like, you're looking at. at the accountant and like, you're sort of, your, your gaze is kind of like dear in headlights. Oh, it was. Like, because you have no idea who's making the paper. And I went over this with my wife. I, uh, when I was getting ready for bed last night, I said, Stephanie, I'm doing, uh, office ladies.
And I've seen the office since then. My kids got really into it when they were four. They're now almost nine. But, um, so I'm getting ready for bed. And I said, I'm doing the office. office ladies podcast tomorrow. Do you think I should share that? And she was like, I don't know. And I was like, I said, I find it hard to believe that they would take it so personally and be upset with me. And she was like, yeah, you know, I'm sure it'll be fine. But she said, this morning before I
And I've seen the office since then. My kids got really into it when they were four. They're now almost nine. But, um, so I'm getting ready for bed. And I said, I'm doing the office. office ladies podcast tomorrow. Do you think I should share that? And she was like, I don't know. And I was like, I said, I find it hard to believe that they would take it so personally and be upset with me. And she was like, yeah, you know, I'm sure it'll be fine. But she said, this morning before I|||And I've seen the office since then. My kids got really into it when they were four. They're now almost nine. But, um, so I'm getting ready for bed. And I said, I'm doing the office. office ladies podcast tomorrow. Do you think I should share that? And she was like, I don't know. And I was like, I said, I find it hard to believe that they would take it so personally and be upset with me. And she was like, yeah, you know, I'm sure it'll be fine. But she said, this morning before I
left, she said, make sure you let them know that you have changed and you research now before that, you know, that you're not that same person. So that's my secret on the office. I was absolutely mortified. It felt like one of those moments in life where you're like, I got caught. No, nobody knew. No one knew. It reminds me of the dream, like the anxiety dreams you have.
left, she said, make sure you let them know that you have changed and you research now before that, you know, that you're not that same person. So that's my secret on the office. I was absolutely mortified. It felt like one of those moments in life where you're like, I got caught. No, nobody knew. No one knew. It reminds me of the dream, like the anxiety dreams you have.|||left, she said, make sure you let them know that you have changed and you research now before that, you know, that you're not that same person. So that's my secret on the office. I was absolutely mortified. It felt like one of those moments in life where you're like, I got caught. No, nobody knew. No one knew. It reminds me of the dream, like the anxiety dreams you have.
Acting anxiety dreams, do you have those where you're like, oh my gosh, I have a role and I have to deliver a monologue and it's now and I don't know it and I don't know any of these people. Like that, I've literally had the dream that you lived. I haven't had those, I think, because I don't identify with acting. So there's not even that anxiety. Like, I just don't. You have so much you say on Star Trek. And it's like, it's like engineer speak. And I mean, I one time auditioned for a sci-fi.
Acting anxiety dreams, do you have those where you're like, oh my gosh, I have a role and I have to deliver a monologue and it's now and I don't know it and I don't know any of these people. Like that, I've literally had the dream that you lived. I haven't had those, I think, because I don't identify with acting. So there's not even that anxiety. Like, I just don't. You have so much you say on Star Trek. And it's like, it's like engineer speak. And I mean, I one time auditioned for a sci-fi.|||Acting anxiety dreams, do you have those where you're like, oh my gosh, I have a role and I have to deliver a monologue and it's now and I don't know it and I don't know any of these people. Like that, I've literally had the dream that you lived. I haven't had those, I think, because I don't identify with acting. So there's not even that anxiety. Like, I just don't. You have so much you say on Star Trek. And it's like, it's like engineer speak. And I mean, I one time auditioned for a sci-fi.
I don't think it ever made it. And I was so unbelievable. Like, I love your character because I believe you. I had to say something. Well, because it's TIG in space. Why wouldn't you believe me? It's taken space. I know.
I don't think it ever made it. And I was so unbelievable. Like, I love your character because I believe you. I had to say something. Well, because it's TIG in space. Why wouldn't you believe me? It's taken space. I know.|||I don't think it ever made it. And I was so unbelievable. Like, I love your character because I believe you. I had to say something. Well, because it's TIG in space. Why wouldn't you believe me? It's taken space. I know.
I tried a new version of Angeline's space and it didn't work. I had to say something like, and it was so ridiculous. I was like showing my scar. And I lift up my shirt and I go, got that from a tick tick and sector four. Like, I still remember it. I did not get a call back. Oh, this was an audition? Yes, it was an audition.
I tried a new version of Angeline's space and it didn't work. I had to say something like, and it was so ridiculous. I was like showing my scar. And I lift up my shirt and I go, got that from a tick tick and sector four. Like, I still remember it. I did not get a call back. Oh, this was an audition? Yes, it was an audition.|||I tried a new version of Angeline's space and it didn't work. I had to say something like, and it was so ridiculous. I was like showing my scar. And I lift up my shirt and I go, got that from a tick tick and sector four. Like, I still remember it. I did not get a call back. Oh, this was an audition? Yes, it was an audition.
Oh, for a show that now you think didn't go. I don't think it went. I'm catching up. Yes. Okay. I wasn't even listening. Okay. No, that's not true. But I'm just saying you do well with like big speeches. You are an actor now. I'm, here's the thing is I was on a show called Star Trek Discovery. Yes. That
Oh, for a show that now you think didn't go. I don't think it went. I'm catching up. Yes. Okay. I wasn't even listening. Okay. No, that's not true. But I'm just saying you do well with like big speeches. You are an actor now. I'm, here's the thing is I was on a show called Star Trek Discovery. Yes. That|||Oh, for a show that now you think didn't go. I don't think it went. I'm catching up. Yes. Okay. I wasn't even listening. Okay. No, that's not true. But I'm just saying you do well with like big speeches. You are an actor now. I'm, here's the thing is I was on a show called Star Trek Discovery. Yes. That
wrapped up and ended. My character jumped over to a new Star Trek series that I'm currently filming. Starfleet Academy. Starfleet Academy, starring Holly Hunter. I know. I know. I'm so excited about this. I have a question for you. Go. I didn't want me to enter and Trent. Paul Giamatti is the villain. Incredible cast. I have really struggled with Star Trek dialogue. And on this series, I have a bigger role. And so there was more dialogue. And I was really feeling down on myself because I was like, I'm struggling.
wrapped up and ended. My character jumped over to a new Star Trek series that I'm currently filming. Starfleet Academy. Starfleet Academy, starring Holly Hunter. I know. I know. I'm so excited about this. I have a question for you. Go. I didn't want me to enter and Trent. Paul Giamatti is the villain. Incredible cast. I have really struggled with Star Trek dialogue. And on this series, I have a bigger role. And so there was more dialogue. And I was really feeling down on myself because I was like, I'm struggling.|||wrapped up and ended. My character jumped over to a new Star Trek series that I'm currently filming. Starfleet Academy. Starfleet Academy, starring Holly Hunter. I know. I know. I'm so excited about this. I have a question for you. Go. I didn't want me to enter and Trent. Paul Giamatti is the villain. Incredible cast. I have really struggled with Star Trek dialogue. And on this series, I have a bigger role. And so there was more dialogue. And I was really feeling down on myself because I was like, I'm struggling.
And, you know, I'm on a show with these incredible actors. And it really, I was thinking, I need to, like, step it up. And Stephanie said, I'll put you through my boot camp. but you have to follow everything I tell you. What's her boot camp? Memorizing boot camp? She was saying, essentially, I'll teach you my process, but you have to do everything I tell you. Okay.
And, you know, I'm on a show with these incredible actors. And it really, I was thinking, I need to, like, step it up. And Stephanie said, I'll put you through my boot camp. but you have to follow everything I tell you. What's her boot camp? Memorizing boot camp? She was saying, essentially, I'll teach you my process, but you have to do everything I tell you. Okay.|||And, you know, I'm on a show with these incredible actors. And it really, I was thinking, I need to, like, step it up. And Stephanie said, I'll put you through my boot camp. but you have to follow everything I tell you. What's her boot camp? Memorizing boot camp? She was saying, essentially, I'll teach you my process, but you have to do everything I tell you. Okay.
And so I did that. I was in Toronto working. I saw a new side of my wife I hadn't seen. We've been together 12 years, and she was no joke. She was so intense and serious about doing this, making it work. And I have to say her process has changed my life. I mean, I had done all the typical things of running the lines over and over. I wrote them out a million times.
And so I did that. I was in Toronto working. I saw a new side of my wife I hadn't seen. We've been together 12 years, and she was no joke. She was so intense and serious about doing this, making it work. And I have to say her process has changed my life. I mean, I had done all the typical things of running the lines over and over. I wrote them out a million times.|||And so I did that. I was in Toronto working. I saw a new side of my wife I hadn't seen. We've been together 12 years, and she was no joke. She was so intense and serious about doing this, making it work. And I have to say her process has changed my life. I mean, I had done all the typical things of running the lines over and over. I wrote them out a million times.
I did it with other people or I would record myself saying the other side of the lines. And I was struggling. And her process has made everything so much easier for me. And I'm excited to do not just Star Trek. And this came at the end of season one of this new show. I can't wait to go back to just a regular show where you say, hey, see at the party, and, like, use her process because I even struggled with that kind of thing. I can tell you, Jenna, is geeking out right now.
I did it with other people or I would record myself saying the other side of the lines. And I was struggling. And her process has made everything so much easier for me. And I'm excited to do not just Star Trek. And this came at the end of season one of this new show. I can't wait to go back to just a regular show where you say, hey, see at the party, and, like, use her process because I even struggled with that kind of thing. I can tell you, Jenna, is geeking out right now.|||I did it with other people or I would record myself saying the other side of the lines. And I was struggling. And her process has made everything so much easier for me. And I'm excited to do not just Star Trek. And this came at the end of season one of this new show. I can't wait to go back to just a regular show where you say, hey, see at the party, and, like, use her process because I even struggled with that kind of thing. I can tell you, Jenna, is geeking out right now.
I haven't even looked at you, but this one loves a process. Yeah. I love a process. I didn't care, but, like, I would be on those, you know, Emmy panels with the morning show. And I'm up there with, like, Jen and Reese and John Hamm, all these people, Billy Crutup, and they're asking them about their process. And then I used to try and kind of fake it to be. And then I just, I went rogue one day.
I haven't even looked at you, but this one loves a process. Yeah. I love a process. I didn't care, but, like, I would be on those, you know, Emmy panels with the morning show. And I'm up there with, like, Jen and Reese and John Hamm, all these people, Billy Crutup, and they're asking them about their process. And then I used to try and kind of fake it to be. And then I just, I went rogue one day.|||I haven't even looked at you, but this one loves a process. Yeah. I love a process. I didn't care, but, like, I would be on those, you know, Emmy panels with the morning show. And I'm up there with, like, Jen and Reese and John Hamm, all these people, Billy Crutup, and they're asking them about their process. And then I used to try and kind of fake it to be. And then I just, I went rogue one day.
And I was like, I don't have a clue what's going on. I'm struggling through the whole. And I'm like making jokes. And I thought for sure people were going to be like, you got to. But they were all so amused. And they were like, we're bringing you on every panel. Because I just, I stopped after that first time. trying to pretend like I was, you know, really, I can't compete with those actors that are up there.
And I was like, I don't have a clue what's going on. I'm struggling through the whole. And I'm like making jokes. And I thought for sure people were going to be like, you got to. But they were all so amused. And they were like, we're bringing you on every panel. Because I just, I stopped after that first time. trying to pretend like I was, you know, really, I can't compete with those actors that are up there.|||And I was like, I don't have a clue what's going on. I'm struggling through the whole. And I'm like making jokes. And I thought for sure people were going to be like, you got to. But they were all so amused. And they were like, we're bringing you on every panel. Because I just, I stopped after that first time. trying to pretend like I was, you know, really, I can't compete with those actors that are up there.
But now. But now I'm excited. If they put you on a panel, you are not going to be all joking. I have a process. You have a process. You have to share your wife's process. I mean, not here. You can save it because I'm sure it's like, I don't want you to have to share her process if it's special. No, I'm happy to, especially if it helps somebody. But she basically said when you get your sides, which for people that maybe don't know, No, it's just that scene that you're going to be doing, and it's not the whole script. It's just your scene. She said, read it through, and then write out or type out only your dialogue. And that way, if you get 10 pages, you don't panic thinking, oh, my God, I have 10 pages, because you're just looking at your dialogue, and you'll see maybe only have seven lines in the 10 pages.
But now. But now I'm excited. If they put you on a panel, you are not going to be all joking. I have a process. You have a process. You have to share your wife's process. I mean, not here. You can save it because I'm sure it's like, I don't want you to have to share her process if it's special. No, I'm happy to, especially if it helps somebody. But she basically said when you get your sides, which for people that maybe don't know, No, it's just that scene that you're going to be doing, and it's not the whole script. It's just your scene. She said, read it through, and then write out or type out only your dialogue. And that way, if you get 10 pages, you don't panic thinking, oh, my God, I have 10 pages, because you're just looking at your dialogue, and you'll see maybe only have seven lines in the 10 pages.|||But now. But now I'm excited. If they put you on a panel, you are not going to be all joking. I have a process. You have a process. You have to share your wife's process. I mean, not here. You can save it because I'm sure it's like, I don't want you to have to share her process if it's special. No, I'm happy to, especially if it helps somebody. But she basically said when you get your sides, which for people that maybe don't know, No, it's just that scene that you're going to be doing, and it's not the whole script. It's just your scene. She said, read it through, and then write out or type out only your dialogue. And that way, if you get 10 pages, you don't panic thinking, oh, my God, I have 10 pages, because you're just looking at your dialogue, and you'll see maybe only have seven lines in the 10 pages.
And it can really give you an idea like, oh, I don't need to panic because I just have these seven lines to learn. And then she said, just learn only your lines. Get it to where you can say it basically like an entire monologue. And then once you have that down, then plug it back into the script, to the sides that you have. And then you're fully off book. That's fantastic. And I was like, wow. And she said, and when you've removed just your lines, you can see, oh, I do have a lot of lines, or, oh, I actually don't have that many. And that helped me personally.
And it can really give you an idea like, oh, I don't need to panic because I just have these seven lines to learn. And then she said, just learn only your lines. Get it to where you can say it basically like an entire monologue. And then once you have that down, then plug it back into the script, to the sides that you have. And then you're fully off book. That's fantastic. And I was like, wow. And she said, and when you've removed just your lines, you can see, oh, I do have a lot of lines, or, oh, I actually don't have that many. And that helped me personally.|||And it can really give you an idea like, oh, I don't need to panic because I just have these seven lines to learn. And then she said, just learn only your lines. Get it to where you can say it basically like an entire monologue. And then once you have that down, then plug it back into the script, to the sides that you have. And then you're fully off book. That's fantastic. And I was like, wow. And she said, and when you've removed just your lines, you can see, oh, I do have a lot of lines, or, oh, I actually don't have that many. And that helped me personally.
Right. It's less daunting if you can just see what your part is. Yes. Yeah. And it was easier for me to plug it back in after I isolated things. What do you think of that process? I like it. Do you? Yeah, I do. I might try it. Yeah, I really, it got me so excited, whereas before I'm in a panic, every time I'm on set, and I'm not a panicky, nervous person, but I felt like an imposter, you know, whenever I was on set, because I don't identify with being an actor, and I don't have a process. I'm just scrambling every time. But you are TIG, and you're TIG in space. I'm TIG in space. I'm TIG in the office, and I'm directing my lines to all of the wrong people. And that was just a night. It's been a secret I've carried around for a long time. I'm so glad you could get rid of that.
Right. It's less daunting if you can just see what your part is. Yes. Yeah. And it was easier for me to plug it back in after I isolated things. What do you think of that process? I like it. Do you? Yeah, I do. I might try it. Yeah, I really, it got me so excited, whereas before I'm in a panic, every time I'm on set, and I'm not a panicky, nervous person, but I felt like an imposter, you know, whenever I was on set, because I don't identify with being an actor, and I don't have a process. I'm just scrambling every time. But you are TIG, and you're TIG in space. I'm TIG in space. I'm TIG in the office, and I'm directing my lines to all of the wrong people. And that was just a night. It's been a secret I've carried around for a long time. I'm so glad you could get rid of that.|||Right. It's less daunting if you can just see what your part is. Yes. Yeah. And it was easier for me to plug it back in after I isolated things. What do you think of that process? I like it. Do you? Yeah, I do. I might try it. Yeah, I really, it got me so excited, whereas before I'm in a panic, every time I'm on set, and I'm not a panicky, nervous person, but I felt like an imposter, you know, whenever I was on set, because I don't identify with being an actor, and I don't have a process. I'm just scrambling every time. But you are TIG, and you're TIG in space. I'm TIG in space. I'm TIG in the office, and I'm directing my lines to all of the wrong people. And that was just a night. It's been a secret I've carried around for a long time. I'm so glad you could get rid of that.
You're done with that. Well, I don't ever want to come across as disrespectful. Well, yeah. But now I think time and my career, I'm caught up and I'm like, okay, I'm an actor. I'll say it. Fine. I'm an actor, especially now that I have a process. Oh, yeah.
You're done with that. Well, I don't ever want to come across as disrespectful. Well, yeah. But now I think time and my career, I'm caught up and I'm like, okay, I'm an actor. I'll say it. Fine. I'm an actor, especially now that I have a process. Oh, yeah.|||You're done with that. Well, I don't ever want to come across as disrespectful. Well, yeah. But now I think time and my career, I'm caught up and I'm like, okay, I'm an actor. I'll say it. Fine. I'm an actor, especially now that I have a process. Oh, yeah.
We got a fan question from Linda B. in Riverside, California. Hey, Linda B. Who wanted to know, were you a Star Trek fan before joining the cast of Star Trek? Well, the original series, my brother and I were both into, and we had all the action figures and things like that. But I didn't follow it after I was like five or something. And then my friend Alex Kurtzman, he took over the entire Star Trek universe and
我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州河滨市的琳达·B.的粉丝提问。嘿，琳达·B.。她想知道，在加入《星际迷航》剧组之前，你就是《星际迷航》的粉丝吗？嗯，原版系列我和我哥哥都很喜欢，我们有所有的动作玩偶之类的东西。但我大概五岁左右之后就没怎么追了。然后我的朋友亚历克斯·库茨曼，他接管了整个《星际迷航》宇宙，并且
has helped EP and create all these shows and he and I worked together at, you know, the director Sam Ramey at his company. I was an assistant there. He started out as an assistant and then became like a showrunner
协助担任执行制片人并创作了所有这些节目，他和我曾在导演萨姆·雷米的公司的公司工作过。我在那里当过助理。他也是从助理做起，后来成了运作人
and I went off and did stand-up full-time. And then he brought me in for a meeting and I thought I was going to do an episode or two and then I ended up just being a recurring character on Star Trek Discovery, but after the first episode, I really struggled with my lines. And I called
然后我出去全职做单口喜剧。接着他叫我去开会，我以为我只拍一两集，结果最后我成了《星际迷航：发现号》里的常驻角色，但拍完第一集后，我真的觉得台词很难背。我打电话给
Alex and I said, I know you said you wanted to use me as much as you can. And I, in my mind, I thought they'll probably use me once or twice and I'll go away. But I said, I want you to know I struggled really bad. And if you don't want to use me as much as you want, I was, yeah, I was like, truly don't feel like you have to hold yourself to that. And he said, if you're having trouble with the lines, I'll just make them even harder. Oh, no. What? You just, you know, a friend giving me a hard time.
亚历克斯说，我知道你说过想尽可能多地用我。其实我心里想的是，他们大概用我一两次就会让我走人。但我说，我想让你知道我背台词真的非常吃力。如果你不想像你想象的那样多用我，我真的觉得你没必要勉强自己。然后他说，如果你觉得台词难，我就把台词写得更难。哦，不。什么？你这纯粹是，你知道的，朋友在故意整我。
And he's like, and he also said, and your character will never die. So that's not around the corner. So you're in. Buckle in. Yeah. Oh, that's so great. Yeah. But now it's so fun to be in the.
他说，他还说，你的角色永远不会死。所以你不会那么快杀青的。所以你进组了。系好安全带。是的。哦，太棒了。是的。不过现在能加入这个真是太有趣了。
Star Trek world. My gosh. I have to ask you about Holly Hunter because I just love her. You know, I'll never forget when she was on Inside the Actors Studio, you know, they ask everyone their favorite curse word. And people just sort of say shit or asses for her. And she just looked right at him and said, cock sucker. And I was like, what?
星际迷航的世界。天哪。我得问问霍利·亨特的事，因为我太喜欢她了。你知道的，我永远不会忘记她上《演员工作室内幕》时，你知道的，他们问每个人最喜欢的脏话是什么。大家通常都说“屎”或者“屁股”之类的。而她直接看着主持人说：“操你妈的”。当时我就想，什么？
That is brilliant. And I don't even really know that I really heard anyone say that, like out and about in the world. You have not heard people say that. that time, I was young. Oh. And I just remember being like, yeah. Yeah. I don't know what maybe early 20s. And you had not heard anyone. We're not buying it. No, this seems. I was not familiar. Like, I mean, it was like, Holly's not going to buy that. Oh. No, for real. Like, I remember being like, I'd heard a lot of like curse word, but I was like, cuck sucker. I don't think of that one. That's like, that's fantastic. It is a unique favorite.
这太绝了。而且我甚至不觉得自己真的听过谁在现实生活中随口说出这个词。你没听过别人说那个词吗？那时候我还年轻。哦。我只记得当时心里想：对啊。对啊。我不知道，大概二十岁出头吧。你以前没听过任何人说吗？我们可不买账。不，这看起来。我当时不太熟悉。我是说，当时的感觉就像是，霍利才不会买账呢。哦。不，真的。我记得当时心想，我听过很多脏话，但我当时想：操你妈的？我可没想过那个。这太棒了。这确实是一个独特的，最喜欢的。
Curse word, I'll give you that. Anyway. This is, you guys mentioned nerding out, and this feels kind of nerdy about the way you're discussing that word. Oh. Yeah. Like, you saying it, like, being like, I hadn't really heard that much. And you're saying, yeah, whatever you were just saying, it just felt very nerdy around an unnerdy word. I know.
脏话，这个我承认。不管怎样。你们刚才提到狂热粉丝的感觉，用这种方式讨论那个词听起来有点书呆子气。哦。是的。就像你说的，就好像“我真的没怎么听过那个词”。而你说的，不管你刚才说了什么，在这个不算书呆子气的词面前，感觉非常有书呆子气。我知道。
Well, anyway, I just remember being so surprised by it. And now you get to work with her. And I'm worried that someday if I meet her. that I would have that moment where you just go blah, and I just say something like, I love it when you said cuck sucker. She's going to be like, what are you talking about? No, she would probably hug you for like two minutes. She's very affectionate too. Aw. I mean, she's the commander, right? She's the captain. Yeah. She is the top dog, and she is, man, she's just incredible and she's also so fun. Like before I left Toronto, we had gone out
好吧，不管怎样，我只记得当时被震惊到了。现在你居然能和她合作了。我担心有一天如果我遇到她，我会经历那种语无伦次的一刻，然后脱口而出“我太喜欢你说‘操你妈的’的时候了”。她大概会问：“你在说什么呢？”不，她可能会拥抱你两分钟。她也很热情。天哪。我的意思是，她是长官，对吧？她是船长。是的。她是老大，而且，天哪，她简直太不可思议了，而且她也太有趣了。就像我离开多伦多之前，我们一起出去吃过
for lunch that went five hours no yes yeah yeah that's so cool i mean she's she's an incredible actor and she's a serious actor and she's also so fun and so fun to laugh with you know oh i bet and talk to and she's one of the most curious people i think i've ever met and this i'm always like oh this sounds so weird to say because of course you should be nice to everyone But that's not always a case on sets, especially with somebody as well known and celebrated. But she knows the entire crew's name, their jobs, speaks to everybody, sits down like two inches from their face so interested in their lives. That makes my heart so happy. Yeah, yeah.
午饭，一吃就是五个小时，对，没错，没错，太酷了。我的意思是，她是一位不可思议的演员，是一位严肃的演员，而且她也超级有趣，跟她一起大笑真的很有趣，你知道的。哦，我敢打赌，跟她聊天，她是我见过的最好奇的人之一。我总是觉得，哦，这么说听起来好奇怪，因为你当然应该对每个人都好。但片场并不总是这样，尤其是对于一个如此知名和备受赞誉的人来说。但她知道整个剧组每个人的名字、他们的工作，跟每个人说话，坐得离他们的脸只有两英寸远，对他们的生活表现出极大的兴趣。这让我的心感到非常温暖。对，对。
It's really a nice thing to come across in this industry. So, I have, I have. We're going to pivot. I don't know. Hold on where we're a pivot. Well, we'll cut our whispers. Why would you cut the? I don't want any whispers. Pivot whispers. I don't. I got it. You got it. You got it. You found it. You found it. Okay. Is it the watch? We're not at the watch yet. Everybody, we're going to do a, we're going to do a question about Tick's watch, but we're not there yet. Okay. Okay. Stay tuned. Should I go to my full voice again? Yes. Okay. You found your pivot. I'm not going to.
在影视行业里能遇到这样的人真的很棒。所以，我有，我有。我们要换个话题了。我不知道。等等，我们怎么换话题了。好吧，我们要剪掉我们的耳语。为什么要剪掉？我才不要任何耳语。转折耳语。我不要。我懂了。你懂了。你懂了。你找到了。你找到了。好吧。是这块表吗？我们还没聊到手表呢。大家，我们要聊一个关于蒂格的手表的问题，但我们还没到那一步。好吧。好吧。敬请期待。我是不是该恢复正常的音量了？是的。好吧。你找到你的切入点了。我不打算。
Stay there. I'm going to stay here. Yeah. I'm going to have a cup of tea. Okay. Okay. Tigg, there is a thing about you that is famous, which is that you talk slow. Yes.
就呆这儿。我就呆在这儿。好的。我要喝杯茶。好吧。好吧。蒂格，关于你有一点很有名，那就是你说话很慢。是的。
Yes. You even did a whole bit where you tried to get an auctioneer to train you to talk fast. Yeah. Very funny. Thank you. We reached out to the director of your episode, Test the Store, Brent Forrester, and he sent in an audio clip about what it was like directing you in the episode. And I want you to have a listen.
是的。你甚至做过一整段单口，试图让拍卖师训练你语速快一点。非常搞笑。谢谢。我们联系了你那一集的导演布伦特·福斯特，他发来了一段音频，讲述了在片场指导你的感受。我想让你听听看。
I'm sorry. Should we have given you a heads up? It's hilarious. Oh, my gosh. You probably can see where this is going. For the part of the little girl's mom, Mindy always pictured Tig Natara. We didn't audition anybody.
对不起。我们是不是该先给你打个招呼？太搞笑了。哦，天哪。你大概能猜到接下来会发生什么。为了演那个小女孩的妈妈，明迪一直觉得蒂格·诺塔罗最合适。我们没有试镜任何人。
We just offered it to Tig, and she was great. But at the time, I was concerned about the pacing of the scene. And after the first take, I walked up to Tig. And I said, hey, TIG, I have a thought. And she said, you want me to talk faster? And I said, yeah, how do you know? And she said, every time they put me on camera, they tell me to talk faster. And I said, can you talk faster?
我们直接把这个角色交给了蒂格，她演得非常棒。但在当时，我有点担心那个场景的节奏。拍完第一条后，我走到蒂格面前。我说：“嘿，蒂格，我有个想法。”她说：“你想让我说快一点吗？”我说：“对啊，你怎么知道的？”她说：“每次他们把我拍进镜头，都让我说快一点。”我说：“你能说快一点吗？”
And she said, no, I can't. Do you remember this exchange? I feel like it is an exchange I have on every set. Every set. Like, in fact, it's gotten to the point where when a director comes towards me, I'll put my hand out and say, before you give me any notes, just know I have no range. But go on. What were you going to say? I just, but it's always getting to that of like, okay, and now let's do it faster.
她说：“不，我不能。”你还记得这段对话吗？我觉得这是我在每个片场都会有的对话。每个片场。事实上，情况已经变成了，当导演朝我走过来时，我会伸出手说：“在你给我提任何意见之前，先声明我戏路很窄。但请继续，你刚才想说什么？”我只是，但这总是落到那个点上，就是：“好吧，现在我们加快语速再来一遍。”
And, you know, and I try. But, you know. I just think the beauty in your comedy is your pacing. I just love it. And I feel like I couldn't imagine you tell a story not the way you tell it. Yeah. It's, it's, you know, there's a lot of talk about how just the connection between music and comedy and a lot of musicians want to be comedians. A lot of comedians want to be musicians.
而且，你知道，我也在努力。但是，你知道的。我只是觉得你喜剧的美感就在于你的节奏。我太喜欢了。我觉得我无法想象你用别的方式讲故事。是的。你知道，大家经常讨论音乐和喜剧之间的联系，很多音乐人想当喜剧演员。很多喜剧演员想当音乐人。
and so much of that, I don't know, the timing. Like, it feels like a rhythm and a song to me. The way, like, I can't, the way I deliver my material, it's not thought out. It's just the natural beat and rhythm of the story. And people have asked me, do you decide to pause there for two seconds? or do you decide to,
很大程度上，我不知道，那种时机。感觉就像一首歌的节奏。我表达材料的方式，不是深思熟虑出来的。这只是故事自然的节拍和节奏。有人问过我：“你决定在那里停顿两秒钟吗？还是你决定——”
and I'm like, no, there's no thought. It's truly just how I deliver it. Have you always had that cadence? I mean, I've always been, you know, told I was, yeah, slow and dry, but I think it's highlighted on stage in front of an audience, but it's not on purpose. Mm-hmm. I know just back when I did a ton of improv, you know, you would do a workshop and you would teach these young improvisers.
我说：“不，完全没有想过。这真的只是我表达的方式。”你一直都是这种语速吗？我的意思是，大家一直都说我说话，对，慢而且冷幽默，但我认为这在观众面前的舞台上被放大了，但这并不是故意为之。嗯。我知道以前我做大量即兴表演的时候，你知道的，你会去参加工作坊，然后教这些年轻的即兴表演者。
And I always sort of felt bad saying this because I was like, oh, they're all here to learn. But you can't teach timing. You can teach a lot of things, I feel like, for comedy. But timing is just something instinctual, I think, personally. I do too. And it's a very different timing on and off stage as well. I think that it's just highlighted a little more. Yeah.
我总是有点不好意思这么说，因为我想，哦，他们都是来学习的。但你没法教节奏。我觉得喜剧里很多东西是可以教的，但节奏感纯粹是一种本能，我个人觉得。我也是。而且在舞台上和舞台下的节奏也非常不同。我觉得它在台上只是被稍微放大了一点。对。
Yeah. We got a fan question from Natalie L. in Boston who says, I love you, Tigg. Did you get to practice with the actress who played your daughter prior to the shoot day? No, I did not. I was going to say, I wish I had, but I don't even know. Did you know she was playing your daughter? No, I'm kidding.
对。我们收到了来自波士顿的娜塔莉·L.的粉丝提问，她说：“我太喜欢你了，蒂格。在拍摄当天之前，你有机会和扮演你女儿的女演员一起排练吗？”不，我没有。我本想说，我希望我有，但我甚至不知道。你知道她演你女儿吗？不，开玩笑的。
I honestly don't think I knew anything. Is this person? Yeah, like, why is she stealing my thunder? Why am I referring to her? Get out of my scene, kid. Yeah, no, I didn't run it with anybody. And is this upsetting to the office fans if somebody is like, oh, I hadn't seen it? Um, you know what I mean? Like, I, I know there's rabid fans where they might be offended or something.
老实说，我当时觉得我什么都不知道。是这个人吗？对，就像，她为什么抢我风头？我为什么还要提到她？从我的镜头里滚开，小屁孩。对，没有，我没有跟任何人排练过。办公室的粉丝如果听到有人说“哦，我没看过”会感到沮丧吗？懂我的意思吗？比如，我知道有些狂热粉丝可能会被冒犯什么的。
No. Oh, that you hadn't seen before? No. No, because we've had a lot of different guest stars. Some people were like, I was so nervous because I'd seen every episode. Yeah. And then other people were like, I knew it was a big show, but I hadn't seen it yet. Yeah. Yeah. No. And everyone's experience is completely different. So no. You will not offend anybody. You'll be fine. But I do, I want to mention again that I have seen. many episodes of the office because we were just blown away that our four-year-olds were just like so into it. Do they have a character that they were most like? A lot of little kids like Dwight. Yeah, I was going to guess Dwight. Yeah, it was Dwight. Yeah. Yeah. And I know who Dwight is. Rain. You're not just saying, sure, sure, yeah. No, for sure. For sure. We also have this question from Colton S and Vincent, Ohio. Hey, Colton S. Colton S says, did you break at all during the scene? Did you crack up? If so, who made you break? You might not know.
没有。哦，因为你以前没看过？没有。没有，因为我们有过很多不同的客串明星。有些人会说：“我太紧张了，因为我每一集都看过。”是的。然后还有人会说：“我知道这是一部大剧，但我还没看过。”是的。是的。没有。每个人的经历完全不同。所以不会。你不会冒犯任何人的。没事的。不过我想再次提一下，我已经看过很多集的《办公室》了，因为我们当时惊奇地发现，我们四岁的孩子居然那么喜欢它。他们有没有最像哪个角色的？很多小孩子喜欢德怀特。是的，我猜就是德怀特。对，就是德怀特。对。对。而且我知道德怀特是谁。雷恩。你不是在敷衍我吧？没，绝对没有。绝对没有。我们还有来自俄亥俄州文森特的科尔顿·S.的问题。嘿，科尔顿·S.。科尔顿·S.问：“你在拍摄那个场景时笑场了吗？你崩了吗？如果是的话，是谁逗笑你的？你可能不知道。”
Who made you break? You'd like describe them. I mean, no, I have to say I, I mean, I think I, I'm always amused by Ed Helms. Yes. I mean, he is such a silly man. And I know people know that, but I think he's even sillier than, I don't. I don't. know. I think once you know Ed and then you see his silliness, it's a tickle, it's a deep tickle. So I can just, I don't have a great memory, but I can just assume, I know he was sitting in the front row. I'm just going to assume I was tickled, but I was more so on edge, like terribly on edge that day, because I really, like I said, felt caught. Did you know Ed before you shot on the office?
是谁逗笑你的？你愿意描述一下他们吗？我的意思是，不，我得说，我，我的意思是，我觉得，埃德·海尔姆斯总是能逗乐我。是的。我的意思是，他真的是个很搞笑的人。我知道大家都知道这一点，但我认为他比大家想象的还要搞笑，我不。我不知道。我觉得一旦你了解了埃德，然后看到他的滑稽样，那真是戳中笑点，直击灵魂深处的笑点。所以我可以，我记性不太好，但我可以假设，我知道他当时坐在第一排。我只能假设我被逗乐了，但我当时更多的是处于紧张状态，那天极其紧张，因为就像我说的，我真的觉得自己被抓包了。你在拍《办公室》之前认识埃德吗？
Yeah, not well, I think just through Largo of him doing shows there and I did as well. You're right, though. He is really silly. He's so silly. We used to do the stupidest bits. And I know that I could call him right now and do this stupid bit and he would do it right back. Yeah. I told him this story one time about this girl from my hometown who, if she really liked you, she'd be like, hey, stupid fucking twad. And Ed lost his mind and still to this day, we will say that to each other. And he does it right back the same way. And I'll have to do that too.
对，不是很熟，大概是通过他在拉戈剧院表演时认识的，我也在那里表演过。不过你说得对。他真的很搞笑。他太搞笑了。我们以前经常演一些最蠢的段子。而且我知道我现在就可以打电话给他，表演那个蠢段子，他会立刻接招。是的。我有一次跟他说起我们家乡一个女孩的故事，如果她真的很喜欢你，她就会说：“嘿，你个蠢货。”然后埃德当时笑得前仰后合，直到今天，我们还会互相说这句话。而且他会用同样的方式立刻接话。我也得这么做才行。
Oh, my gosh. Yes. But you've got to do it. Like I'm going down a country road. Yeah, like she's laughing. Like between cigarettes, but. Yeah, he's, I think he's, even though people know he's, he's a comedian, I still think he, it's surprising how silly, deeply silly that man is.
哦，天哪。是的。但你必须这么做。就像我走在乡村道路上。是的，就像她在笑。在抽烟的间隙，但是。是的，他，我觉得他，尽管人们知道他是个喜剧演员，我还是觉得他，那个男人竟然能那么傻，深度的傻，这让人很惊讶。
Yeah, in the best way. Well, Ed Helms famously introduced you for your comedy set that you did that went on to be nominated for a Grammy where you talked about. being very recently diagnosed with breast cancer. When we broke down this episode, I didn't know that I had breast cancer. I had breast cancer, but I didn't know that yet. And so when I listened to your special, I was so moved and I sat in my car just weeping and laughing. It was this cathartic thing and very shortly after that, I was diagnosed with breast cancer and I spent all last year fighting breast cancer. I am now in remission and cancer free. That's amazing. But I just have to say that I just have to say thank you for that because I went back to it
是的，以最好的方式。艾德·赫尔姆斯曾 famously 为你的喜剧专场做过介绍，那个专场后来获得了格莱美提名，你在里面谈到了自己最近被诊断出患有乳腺癌。当我们拆解这一集时，我当时还不知道自己有乳腺癌。我有乳腺癌，但我当时还不知道。所以当我听你的特辑时，我太感动了，我坐在车里又哭又笑。这是一种宣泄，在那之后不久，我就被诊断出患有乳腺癌，我在去年一整年都在与乳腺癌抗争。我现在已经缓解并且癌症康复了。这太棒了。但我必须说，我必须为此对你表示感谢，因为我又回去听了
And it was your line where you say that comedy is tragedy plus time. I thought of that so many times in the very early days because I was like, no, I'm just in the tragedy. Yeah. But there will be time. Yes. And maybe, maybe there will be comedy again one day. Yeah. And so, yeah, what a crazy thing.
还有你的那句名言：喜剧等于悲剧加上时间。在刚开始的那些日子里，我无数次想起这句话，因为我觉得，不，我正身处悲剧之中。是的。但时间会流逝。是的。也许，也许有一天喜剧会再次降临。是的。所以，是的，真是一件疯狂的事。
Yes. And thank you for that. And I'm so glad that you're doing well. And I want to also make sure, and I tried to make it clear in the special that like that isn't my line. I just was repeating a line. Yes, that's like a famous line. But to have you like apply it to your recent diagnosis was so. brilliant and um i was i was just rock bottom in tragedy yeah and also trying to immediately do
是的。谢谢你的那些话。我很高兴你现在情况很好。我也想确保，而且我试图在特辑中表达清楚，那不是我的台词。我只是在重复一句台词。是的，那是一句名言。但你能把它应用到你最近的确诊中，真是太棒了，而且……我当时正处于悲剧的谷底，是的，而且还试图立刻去做
comedy and um and i did not know how it was going to go um just like i didn't know how nobody knows how life is going to go yeah and the audience in the beginning when you said i have cancer at first they didn't know what to do with it they sort of laughed and then and then my god you just had everybody in the palm of your hand it was so honest It was just really beautiful. Well, thank you. I always say it was truly the exact, everybody was perfect in that audience. It was, they carried me through because I had never shared such personal, I mean, when I was diagnosed, I thought I wasn't going to tell anybody.
喜剧，而且……我不知道事情会怎样发展，就像我不知道……没有人知道生活会如何发展。是的，刚开始观众听到你说“我有癌症”时，他们起先不知道该怎么反应，他们有点笑了，然后，然后天哪，你把全场都掌控在手中，太真实了。真的很美妙。哦，谢谢你。我一直说那是完全的，那个观众席上的每个人都是完美的。他们支撑着我，因为我从未分享过如此私人的事情——我是说，当我被诊断出时，我以为我不会告诉任何人。
And I remember calling my manager and saying I have cancer and I don't, I don't want anybody to know. And I had, I mean, just to even back up, I had, prior to that, I had pneumonia. I had this intestinal disease called C. diff that's deadly. It ended up killing my stepfather a couple of years ago. And then I also had cancer. My mother tripped, hit her head and died. My girlfriend and I split up. And then I was diagnosed with cancer. And that was in four months. And I, I, I, I just, I, and it was actually shortly after I had met you, because I remember, I was with my girlfriend at the time, and we had all had a really fun time and exchanged numbers and, you know, and then, and then all of that happened. But, but, yeah, when I went on stage, I just was highly aware of how quickly life and health can just slip away, just gone. and I was at a point in my life and with my health where I couldn't just take a Tylenol or something and turn my health around.
我记得我打电话给我的经纪人，说我有癌症，我不想，我不想让任何人知道。而且我——我是说，回想起来，在此之前，我得了肺炎。我有一种致命的肠道疾病叫艰难梭菌（C. diff）。几年前它最终夺去了我继父的生命。然后我还得了癌症。我母亲摔倒，头部撞击后去世了。我和女友分手了。接着我被诊断出患有癌症。这一切都发生在四个月内。而且，我，我，我，我，而且那其实是在我遇到你不久之后，因为我记得，我当时和我的女友在一起，我们度过了一段非常愉快的时光，交换了电话号码，你知道，然后，然后所有这些事情就发生了。但是，但是，是的，当我走上舞台时，我非常清楚生活和健康会消逝得多么迅速，瞬间就消失了。我当时的生活和健康状况已经无法让我仅仅吃一颗泰诺之类的东西就能扭转健康。
I was just, it was terrifying. So when I went on stage, I thought I love stand-up so much and I want to do it one last time if this is my, I didn't know what was going to happen to me because I was, my body was fighting so much simultaneously. And I had no idea what was going to happen with that. I had no intention of releasing that as an album. It just was all kind of a crazy experience, how it all went down. Did that change your approach to your comedy moving forward? Did it become more personal? I mean, everything changed, but yeah, I opened up in so many ways.
这太可怕了。所以当我走上舞台时，我想我太热爱单口喜剧了，如果这是我的……我不知道会发生在我身上什么，因为我当时，我的身体同时在与太多的事情战斗。我完全不知道会发生什么。我根本没打算把那期节目当作专辑发行。整个过程，事情是怎么发展的，真是一次疯狂的经历。这是否改变了你以后做喜剧的方法？它变得更私密了吗？我是说，一切都变了，但是，是的，我在很多方面都敞开了自己。
I was so private when I was hospitalized with C-Diff, you know and Sarah Silverman only meant good but she had shared pictures of me to another comedian and I was like you don't show her anybody I'm so you know and she was like oh my God I didn't even think about it because I I would share that about myself and I was so closed off and private whereas now I'm like I would I feel like oh yeah I looked like hell I was on my death You know what I mean? Like I don't care when I was first with Stephanie. I had a medical emergency and was in diapers, like walking around in front of her. Like, you know, I kept joking about making like a crinkle, crinkle noise when I'm walking around. But like I just, all of that made me let go of so much. And but then also trying to find the happy medium of I've shared so many things, whether it was through stand-up, I wrote a book, I wrote a TV show, there's a documentary about me, there's so many things. And I realized that I don't have to make myself completely available or share every single thing all the time and talk about silliness.
当我因艰难梭菌住院时，我是那么注重隐私，你知道的，萨拉·西尔弗曼只是出于好意，但她把我的照片分享给了另一个喜剧演员，而我说：“你不准把照片给任何人，我太……”你知道的。她就说：“哦，天哪，我根本没想过，因为我会那样分享我自己的事。”我当时是那么封闭和注重隐私，而现在我觉得：“哦，是的，我看起来像个鬼一样，我都快死了。”你知道我的意思吗？就像我不在乎一样。我和斯蒂芬妮刚在一起时，我有一次医疗紧急情况，穿着尿布，在她面前走来走去。就像，你知道的，我一直在开玩笑说我走来走去时会发出嘎吱嘎吱的声音。但是，所有这些都让我放下了很多。然而，我也在试图寻找一个快乐的中庸之道：我分享了那么多的事情，无论是通过单口喜剧、写书、写电视剧、拍关于我的纪录片，有太多的事情了。我意识到我不需要让自己完全透明，或者总是分享每一件小事，去谈论那些傻气的事情。
I love silliness and I love lighthearted ridiculousness. And so after that time period, I was so thankful and I went on tour and I met with everybody after every show and thanked every – I felt so supported. And then I also realized, like, I'm not really that personality that can sustain this, you know, for this long. And I do direct people to the stuff I've put out. and also sometimes I'll share things, sometimes I won't. And sometimes I'll talk after a show and sometimes I'm just going to go back to my hotel room. And so it's been a whole process of trying to figure out where I am and what I'm going to do or share because I am an earnest person, but I'm also a very ridiculous person. I'm really relating to a lot of what you're saying.
我喜欢傻气，我也喜欢轻松可笑的事情。所以在那个时期之后，我非常感激，我进行了巡演，在每场演出后与每个人见面，感谢每一个——我感到得到了极大的支持。然后我也意识到，我其实不是那种能够长期维持这种状态的人，你知道的。我会引导大家去看我发布的东西，有时候我会分享，有时候不会。有时候我在演出结束后会聊聊天，有时候我只想回我的酒店房间。所以这是一个漫长的过程，去弄清楚我在哪里，我要做什么或分享什么，因为我是一个真诚的人，但我也非常荒谬。我真的对你说的很多话很有共鸣。
I'm kind of hanging on your every word. because I'm also a really private person, and I did not share about my cancer diagnosis for a year. And so I've only just shared, like, last October, and I sort of feel like I'm in that place that you're talking about, about the outpouring of support, and now I do want to talk about it a lot. In fact, in some ways, because when I was going through it, I wasn't emotionally processing it at. at all. It was just, I had to just one step in front of the other. And every time I got through one thing, like when surgery was over, chemo began. And when chemo was over, radiation began. And so I now have my port out and I've done all the big things. I'm just on like a medication that I'll take for five years, which is what's giving me the hot flashes, which is why I keep taking
我简直是在听你说的每一个字。因为我也是一个非常注重隐私的人，我有一年的时间没有分享我的癌症诊断。所以我直到去年十月才刚刚分享，我感觉自己处于你所说的那个状态中，感受着如潮的支持，现在我确实想多谈谈它。事实上，在某种程度上，因为当我经历它时，我根本没有在情感上消化它。我只是必须一步接一步地走。每当我熬过一关，比如手术结束后，化疗就开始了。化疗结束后，放疗就开始了。所以我现在拔掉了静脉输液港，做完了所有大事。我只是在吃一种需要吃五年的药，这就是让我潮热的原因，也是我一直在...
my coat on and off in this interview. And because you're terribly indecisive. And I can't decide if I want this coat off. Yeah. No. I can't. Is this the fit? Yeah. Is this the fit? It's both things. Yeah. And they're working against each other.
穿脱这件外套的原因。因为你极其优柔寡断。我无法决定是否要把这件外套脱掉。对。不。我不能。这是合适的穿搭吗？是的。这是合适的穿搭吗？两者都是。是的。它们在互相对抗。
But yeah, I think now I've only had time to think, oh, my God, what just happened? Yeah. What the fuck just happened to me? And so I'm doing that same thing where I'm figuring out, like, well, how much do I want to talk about that publicly? How much do I want to talk about it privately? Mm-hmm. I don't know. It's a lot.
但是，是的，我觉得现在我才有时间去想：“哦，天哪，刚刚发生了什么？”是的。“他妈的刚刚到底发生了什么？”所以我正在做同样的事情，去弄清楚，好吧，我在公开场合想谈论多少？在私底下我又想谈论多少？嗯。我不知道。这太沉重了。
Sure. I mean, it took me a long time. You know, I was backlogged with emotional distress. And because I was so guarded in my life, I remember, like, the news had come out that I was sick. And then as soon as I had a double mastectomy and the doctors felt like they had gotten everything under control, I wanted immediately to go on Conan and share that I'm okay. Like, I didn't want anybody to think I'm not okay. I'm, you know, I'm moving along. Everything's all right. And that was kind of how I was going through life.
当然。我是说，这花了我很长时间。你知道，我积压了太多的情绪困扰。因为我在生活中防备心很重，我记得，当时有新闻爆出说我生病了。然后一旦我做了双侧乳房切除术，医生觉得一切都在控制之中时，我立刻就想去上柯南的节目，分享我没事的消息。就像，我不想让任何人觉得我有事。我，你知道的，我正在向前走。一切都好。这差不多就是我当时过生活的方式。
And I took a job and I was working on a TV show. But meanwhile, my mother just tripped and died. And meanwhile, I still have incisions like stitches across my chest while I'm working on this new show and I don't have a primary relationship. and I just, I was so lost and confused, but I was, it took me a while to really catch up with what was going on with my body and my mind. And I remember I moved back to L.A. after working on that job and I sat on my couch and I felt like I was going to fall off of the planet. I don't know if it was a panic attack, but I didn't feel stable on the couch. And you know, it's crazy.
我接了一份工作，在拍一部电视剧。但与此同时，我母亲刚刚摔倒去世了。与此同时，当我正在拍这部新剧时，我胸前还有着缝合的伤口，而且我没有亲密伴侣。我只是，我太迷茫和困惑了，但我一直在，我花了很长时间才真正追赶上我身体和心灵上发生的事情。我记得拍完那部剧后我搬回了洛杉矶，坐在沙发上，我觉得自己快要从地球上掉下去了。我不知道那是不是恐慌发作，但我感觉在沙发上坐不稳。你知道，这太疯狂了。
This is also very odd to tie it all back. March 1st, I am confident, is when my episode of The Office aired, and that was the first time I got any symptom. I remember I was home with my girlfriend, and my throat hurt, and I wasn't feeling well. And I just thought I had a cold or something, but I had gotten bronchitis or something, and then it turned into pneumonia. and then I had gone to get antibiotics, and that is what caused me to contract C-DIF, and then it just kept going and going and going. But March 1st, I sat and watched the episode of the office, so I did finally see an episode of the office. But that was the beginning, March 1st of 2012, was when my life just started to slide away,
把这一切串联起来也很奇怪。3月1日，我很确信，正是我参演的那集《办公室》播出的日子，那也是我第一次出现任何症状。我记得我和女友在家，我的喉咙痛，我感觉很不舒服。我只以为自己感冒了什么的，但我得了支气管炎之类的病，然后演变成了肺炎。然后我去拿了抗生素，正是那个导致我感染了艰难梭菌，然后病情就不断地恶化、恶化、恶化。但在3月1日，我坐下来看了那集《办公室》，所以我终于看到了那集《办公室》。但那是开始，2012年3月1日，正是我的生活开始滑向深渊的时候，
and my mother died on March 28th, and I was hospitalized mid-mart, like right now. I was still hospitalized with C. diff. But anyway, so it just took me a very long time to catch up because once I went through and had my surgery and I moved out to New York to work on this show. And I just was trying to keep things going. I'm fine. I'm okay. No problem. I can handle anything, you know. I remember. The moment you got still is when I almost fell off. It all caught up with you. The face of the earth. I truly was like, what is happening? I felt. it's so unstable. Yeah. Yeah. I totally get that. I also had this desire as soon as I told everybody that I was being treated for breast cancer. I wanted everyone to know I was okay. Yeah. I didn't want people to worry about me. And I also, I wanted people to know that I could still work. Yeah. I was really afraid that no one would ever hire me again. Same. You know. That's why I called my manager. I remember sitting in the parking lot. I had a loft downtown at the time, and I called my
我母亲在3月28日去世了，我在3月中旬住院了，就像现在这样。我当时还因为艰难梭菌住院。总之，我花了很长时间才恢复过来，因为一旦我经历并做完了手术，我就搬到纽约去拍这部剧。我只是试图让一切继续运转。我很好。我没事。没问题。我能应付任何事，你知道的。我记得。当你安静下来的那一刻，正是我差点掉下去的时候。一切都向你袭来。地球的表面。我真的就像是：“发生了什么？”我感觉。太不稳定了。是的。是的。我完全理解。当我告诉所有人我正在接受乳腺癌治疗时，我也有这种强烈的渴望，我想让每个人都知道我没事。是的。我不想让人们为我担心。而且我也，我想让人们知道我还能工作。是的。我真的很害怕再也没有人会雇佣我。我也是。你知道的。这就是为什么我打电话给我的经纪人。我记得坐在停车场里。当时我在市中心有一个阁楼，我打电话给我的
manager, and I said, do not tell anybody, because I really was so scared that people would take work from me. Yeah. That's so sad, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, because I know what a worry that was for you, Jenna. And she went to such great lengths. You know, we had all these meetings. We were changing, you know, we were starting to meet with Odyssey, which is who we're with now for the podcast. And we had all of these Zoom meetings. And Jenna created this wig hat. It was like a baseball cap with a wig that you. It had like my, my hairstylist came up with it.
经纪人，我说，千万不要告诉任何人，因为我真的很害怕人们会夺走我的工作。是的。这太悲伤了，不是吗？是的。我是说，因为我知道这曾经让你多么焦虑，珍娜。她付出了巨大的努力。你知道，我们开了所有这些会议。我们正在改变，你知道的，我们开始与奥德赛（Odyssey）会面，也就是我们现在做播客的这家公司。我们开了所有这些Zoom会议。珍娜制作了一顶假发帽。就像是一顶带有假发的棒球帽。它就像我的，我的发型师想出来的。
It's, you know, almost like a mullet hat. I was like, why can't I take my old hair extensions and glue them into a hat? Yeah. And she was like, you can. And you guys, what do you call you had a name for it? We called them wiggets. A wigget. And I had four.
你知道的，有点像鲻鱼头帽子。我说：“为什么我不能把我以前的头发接发胶粘在帽子里呢？”是的。她说：“你可以。”然后你们，你们叫什么名字，你们给它起过一个名字？我们叫它们小假发（wiggets）。一个小假发。我有四个。
That's amazing. I had different colors, so I could switch them out. And then I also had these headbands that had hair. So I could put those on as well. I also had wigs because my hair was falling out, but I hadn't told anybody. So I did have some, like, awkward school functions where, like, a hat wasn't really appropriate. Did you have any... But I wore it anyway.
这太棒了。我有不同的颜色，所以我可以换着戴。然后我还有这些带头发的发带。所以我也可以戴那些。我还有假发，因为我的头发在掉，但我还没告诉任何人。所以我确实经历了一些尴尬的学校活动，比如戴帽子其实不太合适。你有没有……但我还是戴了。
Did you have any headphone wigs? No, for podcasting. I didn't. I didn't. But that would be perfect. kid's school and you're like, sorry, I'm running late. I have to record the podcast. I just forgot. Oh, are these still on? Yeah. Anyway. Well, I don't want to take them off now. No, because my hair will look weird and it is my hair. It really is. No one. Don't be concerned.
你有没有戴耳机假发？没有，为了做播客。我没有。我没有。但那会很完美。去孩子的学校，然后你说：“抱歉，我迟到了。我得录播客。我刚刚忘了。”哦，这些还戴着吗？是的。不管怎样。好吧，我现在可不想摘下来。不，因为我的头发看起来会很怪，而且这就是我的头发。真的是这样。没人。别担心。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Nothing is seeing here. Yeah. No, but we would, I would sometimes just on Zoom, I would just like put the camera in a way. Yeah. So that you couldn't see the top of my head. And then I could just wear the headband wig. I started wearing hats and I'm not meant to wear a hat. No. It makes, I just kind of look like a kind of a short, like budgy man. I don't know. My face is so round. Like I put a hat on and I'm like, like, I'm like a little, I'm like a little tortoise. This is not true. She has a thing where she does braids with a hat. Because without the braids, I just look like a little tortoise man. A tortoise man. Yeah, I'm a tortoise. I look like a tortoise man with or without a hat.
对，对，对。这里什么都没看见。是的。不，但是我们会，我有时只是在Zoom上，我会把摄像头调成某个角度。是的。这样你就看不到我的头顶了。然后我就可以只戴那个发带假发。我开始戴帽子，而我其实并不适合戴帽子。不。这让，我看起来有点像一个矮胖的，像个短小敦实的男人。我不知道。我的脸太圆了。就像我戴上一顶帽子，我就觉得，就像，我像个小乌龟。这不是真的。她有一个绝招，就是在戴帽子时编辫子。因为不编辫子的话，我看起来就像一个小乌龟人。一个乌龟人。是的，我是个乌龟。无论戴不戴帽子，我都看起来像个乌龟人。
I get called, sir. Oh, ladies. Excuse me, but everywhere I go, I'm called sir. Yes, I answered a lady. We are not calling ourselves tortoise men on this podcast. All right, all right, fine. We are going to be kind to ourselves. We are office ladies.
我经常被称为“先生”。哦，女士们。不好意思，但无论我走到哪里，我都被称为“先生”。是的，我回答了一位女士。我们在这个播客里可不自称乌龟人。好吧，好吧，好吧。我们要对自己好一点。我们是《办公室女士》。
We are not tortoise men. Thank you. We are. That's the spin-off. We're handsome ladies. Yes. Yes, we are. But, no, we did.
我们不是乌龟人。谢谢。我们是。这就是衍生节目。我们是英俊的女士。是的。是的，我们是。但是，不，我们确实。
We wore a lot of hats. And I just, I was just, whatever, Jenna and I've been down this road a lot because it's hard not to get emotional when you don't know how to be there for someone you care so much about. Yeah. You know? Well, I mean, but that is what you do is you just show up to be with your friend and whatever comes with that in that moment. I remember my big experience, I guess, as a young adult was my very closest friend from my childhood who was all. also the godmother of my kids, her sister killed herself. And I was so scared. And I called my mother. And I was like, what do I do? And she said, you hang up the phone with me. You drive over to
我们戴了很多帽子。我只是，随便吧，珍娜和我经常经历这些，因为当你不懂得如何陪伴一个你深爱的人时，很难不情绪化。是的。你知道吗？好吧，我是说，但这就是你要做的，你只是出现去陪伴你的朋友，在那个时刻随之而来的是什么。我记得我作为年轻成年人的巨大经历，我想，是我童年最要好的朋友，她也是我孩子的教母，她的姐姐自杀了。我当时吓坏了。我打电话给我妈妈。我说：“我该怎么办？”她说：“你挂掉我的电话。你开车去
her house and you just sit with her. And I was like, yeah, okay. And I did. And it was so hard and it was so uncomfortable. And it was all of these things. But it changed my life. And I am, man, do I live by that rule. Like, I will be there. I will absolutely be there. And I always think any hard thing I go through, I'm going to be alive after this uncomfortable thing. I'm going to be alive after this hard phone call. I'm going to be, I'm going to live through this. It's just going to be really hard. It's going to be really uncomfortable. But nothing feels better than hanging up the phone, driving over. and just being with somebody that you care about. And I had incredible friends. I don't know how you, you know, handled or went through and how, whatever. But I was like on lockdown. I didn't want any peripheral friends.
她家，然后就在那里陪着她。”我说：“好吧，好的。”我照做了。这太难了，也太让人不舒服了。所有这些都是。但它改变了我的生活。天哪，我是多么笃信这个准则。就像，我会陪在那里。我绝对会陪在那里。我总是想，我经历的任何艰难的事情，在这个让人不舒服的事情之后，我都会活下来的。在这个艰难的电话之后，我会活下来的。我会，我会挺过这一关的。这只是会非常艰难。会非常不舒服。但没有什么比挂了电话、开车过去、和你在乎的人在一起更让人感觉美好了。我有着不可思议的朋友们。我不知道你是怎么，你知道，处理或经历的，或者别的什么。但我当时就像在闭关。我不需要任何泛泛之交。
I didn't want, I just wanted my people. Your inner circle. Yeah. Yeah. And that was it. And I just really struggled with. opening myself up, but I feel like I've done both, aside from being there for people, allowing people to be there for me. Yeah, I had a really great group of very supportive friends,
我不想，我只想要我的人。你的核心圈子。对。对。就是这样。我真的很挣扎。敞开心扉，但我感觉这两件事我都做到了，除了陪伴在别人身边，也允许别人陪伴在我身边。对，我有一群非常棒、非常支持我的朋友，
and those were the people that we shared with. Yeah. But I didn't share very widely. So there were a lot of people that I do consider to be my friend who I did not share with for a long time. but I needed those people. I needed there to be like moms at the school who didn't know who just came up to me with like school gossip, you know, people who weren't talking to me about cancer and how I felt. Yeah. And so I love them for that, for not knowing. And I also did have some people who I told who I thought would show up for me and they didn't. Yeah.
这些人就是我们倾诉的对象。对。但我没有广泛倾诉。所以有很多我认为是朋友的人，我很久都没有对他们倾诉。但我需要这些人。我需要学校里那些什么都不知道的妈妈们，她们只是走过来跟我聊聊学校八卦，你知道的，那些不跟我谈论癌症以及我感觉如何的人。对。所以我很感激她们什么都不知道。我也确实告诉了一些我以为会支持我的人，但他们没有。对。
They didn't have the capacity to come and be with me in this, and I forgive them. It's okay. Same. It's just some people have that, and I think it was just whatever so real or scary for them that they couldn't do it. And that's okay. And I'm still friends with them. I, one million percent, experience the same thing.
他们没有能力来陪我度过这一切，我原谅他们。没关系。我也是。只是有些人有那种情况，我觉得无论对他们来说是多么真实还是可怕，以至于他们做不到。没关系。我仍然和他们是朋友。我百分之百经历过同样的事情。
And it was that learning curve in life where you go, I know they love me. Yeah. And I know they're not able to do this for whatever reason. And it, but I did at first get my feelings hurt. I did too. And then when I really thought it through, I was like, this is not because they're a bad person or they don't care about me. They just don't have that ability. And then there were the people that surprised me as well.
那是人生中的一个学习曲线，你会说，我知道他们爱我。对。我知道他们无论出于什么原因无法做到这一点。起初我的心确实受伤了。我也是。然后当我真正想通了之后，我想，这不是因为他们是坏人或者他们不在乎我。他们只是没有那种能力。然后还有那些让我感到惊讶的人。
The people who I had maybe thought weren't going to have the capacity to go through that with me. And they did. And I'm, wow. It's really mind-blowing when that happens. Yeah. Just puts everything under a magnifying glass, I would imagine, right? Yes, everything becomes more in focus. When people step into a really messy, terrible, rough situation, and they're not.
那些我原本以为没有能力陪我经历这一切的人。但他们做到了。我，哇。当这种事情发生时，真的很震撼。对。我想这会把一切都放在放大镜下审视，对吧？是的，一切都变得更加聚焦。当人们步入一个非常混乱、糟糕、艰难的局面时，他们并不是。
Not. I mean, that's already a big deal when it's your crew. And then when it's somebody just a little outside or even a lot outside, and they're like, I'm here. Let's go. Yeah. Yeah. It's really incredible. Yeah. Yeah. Well, switching gears. As we do. As we do. You are such a multifaceted artist and we got a lot of fan questions about your work. multi-faceted. I like that word. I want to be a multi-hat. Like, what is it called on Wikipedia when you have multiple paragraphs? A multi-hyphenate? Yes. You're a multi-hyphenate.
不是。我的意思是，当这是你的死党时，这已经是一件大事了。然后当是一个稍微局外一点，甚至大大局外的人，他们说，我在这里。我们走吧。对。对。真的太不可思议了。对。对。好吧，换个话题。我们经常这样。我们一贯如此。你是一位如此多面手的艺术家，我们收到了很多粉丝关于你的作品的提问。多面手。我喜欢这个词。我想成为一个多重身份的人。等等，在维基百科上，当你有多个段落时，这叫什么？全能斜杠青年？对。你是一个斜杠青年。
Yes, I want to be that. You are. You are. Both of you are. We've got some hyphens. We do. We have one or two, not as many as you. You're hyphenates? No, you're super hyphenate, though.
是的，我想成为那样的人。你就是。你就是。你们两个都是。我们都有一些斜杠。我们确实有。有一两个，没有你那么多。你们是斜杠青年吗？不，不过你是超级斜杠青年。
Okay, back to you, Tick. Emily P. Indianapolis said, TIG has been in so many things, but I wanted to know what her favorite project is. I just love when she comes up on my screen. I think the office is the first place I saw her, but I love her stand up. I love her on Bob's Burgers, on New Girl. I loved her in the movie Instant Family. There are so many options, but I want to know what TIG enjoyed the most or is most proud of. Well, it's sadly not the office. What? How dare you? I was proud of it. I was proud of it. I was proud of, to be on there, but I was not proud of my work any time. And what's so crazy is some people only
好吧，回到你身上，蒂格。印第安纳波利斯的埃米莉·P说，蒂格演过那么多作品，但我相知道她最喜欢哪个项目。我就是喜欢她在我的屏幕上出现。我想《办公室》是我第一次看到她的地方，但我喜欢她的单口喜剧。我喜欢她在《开心汉堡店》和《杰茜驾到》中的表现。我喜欢她在电影《速成家庭》中的表现。有太多的选择了，但我相知道蒂格最喜欢哪个或者最为哪个感到骄傲。好吧，遗憾的是不是《办公室》。什么？你怎么敢？我为它感到骄傲。我为它感到骄傲。我为能够参与其中感到骄傲，但我对自己任何时候的表现都不感到骄傲。最疯狂的是有些人只
know me from the office. Do you get recognized a lot? Yes. And I can't believe when people come up and they're like, oh my gosh, I loved you on the office. I'm like, what? It reminds me of, but it's also, obviously, that show is so enormous. Yeah. You know Kate McCutche and Ricky Linholm. They were Garfunkel and Oates, musical comedy duo. Okay. I don't know them. Okay. Well, very funny. They're no longer performing as Garfunkel and Oates anymore, but Can we find them on the internet? Yes. Okay. And it's, it's, uh, is it delightful? I can't wait. It's so delightful because they're both like fresh, sweet-faced singing, not so fresh, sweet-faced. Okay. Okay. And, uh, but,
通过《办公室》认识我。你经常被认出来吗？是的。当人们走过来对我说，哦天哪，我太喜欢你在《办公室》里的表现了，我简直不敢相信。我说，什么？这让我想起，但这也是，显然，那部剧太火了。对。你知道凯特·麦卡库奇和瑞奇·林霍姆吗。她们是“加芬克尔与奥茨”音乐喜剧二人组。好的。我不认识她们。好吧。非常搞笑。她们不再以“加芬克尔与奥茨”的名义表演了，但是我们能在互联网上找到她们吗？可以。好的。而且，它是，它是，呃，很令人愉快吗？我迫不及待了。太令人愉快了，因为她们俩都像清新、甜美面孔的歌手，其实也不是那么清新甜美。好吧。好吧。而且，呃，但是，
Anyway, they had a TV show on IFC for a while, and again, friends that had me come on their show. And I was in one scene, very short scene, and I was going to Florida to work out material for my upcoming special. And so I was just doing a few quick club dates. And when I got there, the poster said Tignotaro from Garfunkel in Oates. That was my one credit. And it was clearly somebody that worked at the club that just was not familiar with me, Googled me. That was the first thing they saw. They just slapped it on.
不管怎样，她们在IFC上有一个电视节目一段时间，同样，是朋友们邀请我上他们的节目。我演了一个场景，非常短的场景，我要去佛罗里达州为我即将到来的专场打磨段落。所以我只是做了一些简短的俱乐部演出。当我到达那里时，海报上写着来自“加芬克尔与奥茨”的蒂格·诺塔罗。那是我的唯一演职员署名。这显然是俱乐部里的某个人根本不熟悉我，谷歌了一下我。那是他们看到的第一个东西。他们直接贴上去了。
Way to go, buddy. And it's like, no offense, IFC. I don't even know if that exists anymore. But I'm certain maybe 50,000 people watched IFC. IFC, you know? So anyway, I was very excited to do the office. I was very flattered. I was very honored, but I just did not do anything I was proud of.
干得好，老兄。这就像是，无意冒犯，IFC。我甚至不知道那现在还存不存在。但我确信也许有5万人在看IFC。IFC，你知道吗？所以无论如何，我非常高兴能出演《办公室》。我感到非常受宠若惊，我感到非常荣幸，但我真的没有做出什么让我感到骄傲的事情。
What have I enjoyed? That is really a hard question. It is. It is really hard because it's like mentioning instant family. I was a social worker with Octavia Spencer, And we just had the greatest time. Rose Byrne, who is this silly, I mean, I love her. She is a freak of nature, her talent between drama and comedy.
我享受过什么？这真的是一个难题。确实如此。这真的很难，因为就像提到《速成家庭》一样。我和奥克塔维亚·斯宾塞一起扮演社工，我们度过了最美好的时光。罗斯·伯恩，她是一个傻乎乎的，我的意思是，我爱她。她在戏剧和喜剧之间的天赋简直是大自然的奇迹，
I can't even stand it. I love that. But, you know, I do. I have a lot of pride, even though I struggle through my lines doing Star Trek. And I'm now, as I mentioned before, I'm more excited to approve. myself now that I have a process. A process. And that fandom, that is, I mean, it's like the office. That rival's the office. No, it's, it's bigger. It's because it's just been around for so long and you're part of that universe now. I mean, William Shatner is almost 100 years old. I think he's
我都快受不了了。我喜欢那样。但是，你知道，我确实。我有很多自豪感，尽管我在《星际迷航》中背台词很挣扎。正如我之前提到的，我现在更加兴奋去证明自己，因为我现在有了一套流程。一套流程。而那个粉丝群体，那，我的意思是，就像《办公室》。那可以与《办公室》媲美。不，它，它更大。因为它的存在时间太长了，你现在已经是那个宇宙的一部分了。我的意思是，威廉·夏特纳快100岁了。我想他
95. And he still jets off every weekend to a convention. And I mean, have you seen this guy talk? Yes, I saw him on, I forgot the late night talk show, but he was like doing bits. I mean, this guy has no clue. He's almost 100. Yeah. Like somebody needs to tell his face this because he's just like walking around like he's not 95. You can take the weekend off. Truly.
95岁了。他仍然每个周末都坐飞机去参加动漫展。我的意思是，你见过这家伙说话吗？是的，我在，我忘了哪个深夜脱口秀节目上看到过他，但他就像是在演段子。我的意思是，这家伙完全没概念。他快100岁了。对。就好像有人需要把这事告诉他的脸，因为他走起路来根本不像95岁。你可以周末休息一下。真的。
You can put your feet up. Yeah. Yeah. And then I also, I have a small part on the morning show. And it's really fun to do just like a. dramatic, you know, yeah, show. Fast-talking drama. Yeah.
你可以把脚翘起来休息。对。对。然后我也，我在《早间新闻》里有一个小角色。演一个像这样的戏剧，你知道，对，节目，感觉真的很棒。语速极快的剧情片。对。
And I've known so many of those cast members in so many different ways over the years. And so that's fun, too. Part of what I enjoy about acting is this really highlights how much I'm not an actor, but when they say cut and then I get to talk to. Then you get to do the chitty chat. Then I get to talk to my co-stars. That is one of the best parts of being an actor, is just existing. with all of these, like, incredibly creative, funny, interesting people.
这些年来，我以各种不同的方式认识了许多这样的演员。所以这也很酷。我喜欢表演的一部分原因在于，这真正凸显了我有多么不是一个演员，但当他们喊停时，我有机会去跟。然后你就可以进行闲聊了。然后我有机会跟我的联合主演聊天。做演员最好的部分之一，就是能够和所有这些极其有创意、有趣的人一起存在。
Yeah. I mean, artists and actors are interesting. Yeah. Yeah. So, I don't know. Those are the two things I'm working on these days that I'm fresh in my mind and I'm enjoying them. Those are decent, you know. They're not too shabby.
对。我的意思是，艺术家和演员都很有趣。对。对。所以，我不知道。这些是我这些天正在做的两件事，它们在我的脑海中还很新鲜，我很享受它们。这些都还不错，你知道的。它们不算太差。
Yeah, I've really enjoyed everything. Like, I, you know, there's been some rotten people in the mix here and there. but in general, I've had a really great run. Can I ask you about the watch now? So in your new comedy special. Hello again. Directed by your wife. She was nominated for an Emmy.
对，我真的很享受一切。就像，你知道，其中夹杂着一些讨厌的人，但总的来说，我度过了一段非常棒的时光。我现在可以问你关于手表的事吗？所以在你的新喜剧专场中。再次问候。由你的妻子执导。她获得了一项艾美奖提名。
Stephanie Allen. Yep. Fantastic. I loved your special. Thank you. I couldn't help but notice that you have on a fantastic watch. Thank you. And I asked you when you came in, I want to hear about the watch.
斯蒂芬妮·艾伦。是的。太棒了。我很喜欢你的专场。谢谢。我禁不住注意到你戴着一块非常棒的手表。谢谢。你进来的时候我问过你，我想听听关于这块手表的故事。
And you said there's a great story about this watch. And I'm sorry I didn't notice the watch. Oh, that's fine. I thought the lighting was beautiful. Well, thank you. I was like, oh, there's a story because I was thinking how it ties in also to cancer. Oh. Years ago, I was guest starring on the Sarah Silverman program, and there was an actress that came on there that I had a really fun banter with an exchange to the point where I was like, geez, cute.
你说关于这块手表有一个很棒的故事。我很抱歉我没有注意到这块手表。哦，没关系。我觉得灯光很美。哦，谢谢。我当时想，哦，这里有个故事，因为我在想它跟癌症是怎么联系起来的。哦。多年前，我在《萨拉·西尔弗曼节目》中客串演出，那里来了一位女演员，我和她进行了非常有趣的玩笑和交流，以至于我觉得，天哪，真可爱。
But I was like, she's not into me, so that's fine. She was engaged to marry this guy and whatever, but I still thought she was so funny and it was just fun every time I saw her, worked with her. Years go by, and then I run into her right before I'm moving to New York to work on that TV show, and I hadn't been diagnosed yet, but we were at a table read together. A friend of ours was doing a Broadway play. wanted us to read through this script with her. And afterwards, we found out we were both moving to New York at the same time.
但我当时想，她对我不感兴趣，所以没关系。她当时跟这个家伙订婚了什么的，但我仍然觉得她很有趣，每次我看到她、和她一起工作，都觉得很有趣。几年过去了，就在我搬到纽约去拍那个电视节目之前，我又遇到了她，我当时还没被诊断出来，但我们在做一次剧本围读。我们的一个朋友在排演一出百老汇戏剧。她想让我们和她一起通读这个剧本。之后，我们发现我们都要同时搬到纽约。
Well, she was divorce now. And we exchanged numbers. And, well, it turns out there was something between us. And then I was diagnosed in the middle of that. And I was very insecure because I was like, oh, my gosh, I can't believe this woman that I thought was so attractive and fun, and I'm getting her attention now. And now just buzzkill, I just got diagnosed with cancer. And she was so good to me during that time and helpful.
嗯，她现在离婚了。我们交换了电话号码。然后，好吧，原来我们之间有些火花。然后我在那期间被诊断出患有癌症。我非常没有安全感，因为我想，哦天哪，我真不敢相信这个我曾经觉得很有吸引力和趣的女人，现在开始注意到我了。而现在却成了一个扫兴的时刻，我刚刚被诊断出患有癌症。在那段期间，她对我非常好，也帮了很多忙。
And then I had my surgery. I didn't have reconstructive surgery. And so I do still just have scars on my chest. And I remember also feeling very insecure about my body for a while. And when I talked to her about that, she was like, I love scars. I think scars are so hot and sexy. And I was like, what?
然后我做了手术。我没有做乳房重建手术。所以我胸部确实还是留有伤疤。我记得有一段时间我对自己的身体也感到非常没有安全感。当我跟她谈到这一点时，她说，我喜欢伤疤。我觉得伤疤非常性感迷人。我当时想，什么？
I was like, well, I got something to offer you. I got scars. I got scars all the live long day. I was like, you like scars? And she was like, yeah, I love scars. And I was like, oh my gosh. And so I have this, you know, a fling. I don't even know what it was that was going on between us.
我当时想，好吧，我有点东西可以献给你了。我有伤疤。我有说不完的伤疤。我说，你喜欢伤疤？她说，对，我喜欢伤疤。我当时想，哦天哪。所以我有了这个，你知道，一段露水情缘。我甚至不知道我们之间到底在发生什么。
But she had the, it's a Rolex watch. and for whatever, oh, we had exchanged watches. She had a Rolex. I had a Timex and just one of those little plastic digital watches. And so we exchanged watches while we were having our fling or whatever was going on. And then when it ended, I went to give her her watch back, and she said, I want you to keep that. And I was like, oh, I can't keep your Rolex. And she was like, I want you to have it. And I was like, wow. And so I walked away with a
但她有，那是一块劳力士手表。无论出于什么原因，哦，我们交换了手表。她有一块劳力士。我有一块天美时，就是那种小小的塑料电子表。所以我们在暧昧或者无论发生什么的时候交换了手表。然后当它结束时，我把手表还给她，她说，我希望你留着。我说，哦，我不能留着你的劳力士。她说，我希望你拥有它。我说，哇。所以我带着一块
Rolex. Wow. Yeah. That is an amazing story. And she does like scars. I will confirm. It's really under scars. You got the gift of this person being completely, truly, like, turned on and attracted to you in this new form that you were so insecure about. And you got to a luxury watch out of this relationship. I am not. I don't think it gets better than that. No. And I am not somebody that, I'm just, I never would have bought a Rolex. Right. Yeah. I'm in a, I realize driving here, I'm in a flannel, not a flannel. What is this? Like a ribbed, long sleeve thermal. Yeah. That's inside out. I thought, you know what? When you sat down, I thought it's either inside out or that's the fashion. No, it's inside out.
劳力士离开了。哇。对。这是一个神奇的故事。而且她确实喜欢伤疤。我可以证实。在伤疤底下，你得到了这份礼物，这个人完全地、真诚地，对你现在的这种新形态感到兴奋并被你吸引，而你以前对这种形态非常没有安全感。而且你还从这段关系中得到了一块奢侈品手表。我不是。我不认为还有比这更好的了。没有。我不是那种人，我只是，我绝不会买一块劳力士。对。对。我意识到，在开车来这里的路上，我穿着一件法兰绒，不是法兰绒。这是什么？就像是罗纹长袖保暖内衣。对。而且是穿反了。我想，你知道吗？当你坐下的时候，我想，要么是穿反了，要么这就是时尚。不，就是穿反了。
So my sons always wear their shirts inside out. I'm always like, on purpose? No. Yeah. Not my buddy. There is a look. There is a fashion where the shirt is made to look inside out. Well, that's not what's happening.
所以我的儿子们总是把衬衫穿反。我总是问，是故意的吗？不是。对。不是老兄。确实有一种造型。有一种时尚是让衬衫看起来像穿反了一样。好吧，我可不是那样。
But what's giving it away, though, is I can see on your chest that there is some writing that is backwards. And I think I'm meant to be able to read it. And let me just tell you, I will be 54 on the 24th of March and when's your birthday? June 25th. I'll be 54. Oh, well, my son's, their birthday, is June 26. Hey. Hey, we got to that point. We got birthdays. I still get excited about stuff like that. I'm like, anyway. But so, okay, so you're going to be 54. And I am somebody's parent. And I walked out of the house and circled the block. But can I just tell you unrelated, but related to being someone's parent this morning, our son, was called out and to speak at the school. Like the circle time? Assembly.
但出卖我的是，我能看到你的胸前有一些倒过来的字。我想我是应该能读懂它的。让我告诉你，3月24日我就满54岁了，你的生日是什么时候？6月25日。我将满54岁。哦，我儿子的生日是6月26日。嘿。嘿，我们聊到这儿了。我们聊到生日了。我还是会对这种事感到兴奋。我心想，不管怎样。但好吧，所以你要54岁了。我是某人的家长。我走出家门，绕着街区走了一圈。但我能不能告诉你一件无关但又跟做某人家长有关的事，今天早上，我们的儿子，被叫到学校去发言。就像围坐时间？全校集会。
Okay. And he got interviewed in front of people at the assembly. And Stephanie and I were there this morning. And they said, is there a woman in your life that is inspiring to you? And he said, my two moms. And it was just like, and I was like, I'm, I'm. I'm always scared. I'm not going to be included in that because, you know, I go on to war. Wait. Well, no, you've told stories. You've shared so many funny stories where, like, you come home and they're like, oh, it's her. Oh, it's her. Oh, yeah. Well, this is the other one. Okay. Yeah. But I was like, I was included in that. And it was so sweet to hear him say, like, my two moms, I love them. And I love being a part of our family. And we were just like, Stephanie turned. She said, did that make you cry? And I was like, yes.
好的。他在集会上当着大家的面接受了采访。斯蒂芬妮和我今天早上也在场。他们问，你生命中有哪个女性对你有所启发？他说，我的两位妈妈。当时的感觉就像是，我心想，我，我。我总是害怕。我不会被包括在内，因为，你知道，我要去……等等。好吧，不，你讲过故事。你分享过那么多搞笑的故事，比如，你回到家，他们说，哦，是她。哦，是她。哦，是的。好吧，这是另一个。好的。对。但我当时想，我被包括在内了。听到他说“我的两位妈妈，我爱她们”真的太甜了。我喜欢成为我们家庭的一部分。我们当时就想，斯蒂芬妮转过身来。她说，这让你哭了吗？我说，是的。
I didn't think I was going to be included. So anyway, I had to throw that in. It was such a nice little moment this morning. All that matters are those moments. That's it. That's all you think of in the quiet times are those moments. Yes. Whenever your kids do that thing.
我以为我不会被包括在内。不管怎样，我不得不提一下。今天早上这是一个多么美好的小时刻。唯一重要的就是这些时刻。就是这样。在安静的时刻里，你所想的全部就是这些时刻。是的。每当你的孩子们做那种事情。
Yes. Like the version of that thing, it just, I'm a puddle. Same. Same. All right. I would like to ask you to our call sheet questions. Okay. These were questions that were on the back of our call sheets.
是的。类似于那种事情的版本，它只是，我整个人都融化了。我也是。我也是。好吧。我想请你回答我们的通告单问题。好的。这些问题曾印在我们通告单的背面。
Okay. And we would, different crew members would get asked each week and then we'd get to read their answers. It was really cool. We'd find out a little something about people that we worked with. Okay. Number one. What was your first entertainment job? Well, before I got into stand-up, I mean, as I mentioned, I think before I'm really into music.
好的。我们每周会问不同的剧组成员，然后我们就能读到他们的回答。真的很酷。我们会对我们一起工作的人有更多的了解。好的。第一题。你的第一份娱乐行业的工作是什么？好吧，在我进入单口喜剧之前，我的意思是，正如我之前提到的，我真的很喜欢音乐。
And I play music, but I also, um, My first girlfriend had a band, and I started booking her band. And so... You were like an agent. I was a booking agent. And I also worked for a record company as a local person when I was living in Denver who would promote their bands. It would come through. I'd have to go hang up flyers and posters and go talk to record stores, make sure they were all their merch and stuff was in.
我玩音乐，但我也，呃，我的第一个女朋友有一个乐队，我开始帮她的乐队预订演出。所以……你就像一个经纪人。我是一个演出经纪人。当我住在丹佛时，我还为一家唱片公司做过当地代表，负责宣传他们的乐队。乐队巡演路过时，我得去挂传单和海报，去唱片行沟通，确保他们的周边商品都顺利上架。
there. And so, yeah, that was my first entertainment job. I love it. I didn't know that. Well, now you know. No, I know. Yeah. This isn't interesting. I have a song I would like to play. No, I'm kidding. Maybe you could get behind. This is a pretty easy segue into our second question, which is do you play a musical instrument? You said you do. I play two. I play guitar and drums. And I'm, um, I'm very good. I'm. better at guitar. I think I'm more natural at drums, but I haven't had time to, I have more of an interest in drums as an adult. You know, if a guitar is sitting around, I could pick it up and play some stuff. But I want to get better. I want to take some lessons and get better at drums. Do you play any, like the guitar or anything for your kids? I mean, we have instruments
所以，是的，那是我的第一份娱乐行业的工作。我喜欢。我不知道。好吧，现在你知道了。不，我知道。对。这不是很搞笑吗。我有一首歌想放一下。不，开玩笑的。也许你可以顺便回答。这很容易过渡到我们的第二个问题，也就是你会乐器吗？你刚才说你会。我会两种。我会弹吉他和打鼓。而且，呃，我非常擅长。我吉他弹得更好。我觉得我在打鼓上更有天赋，但我没有时间，作为成年人，我对打鼓更有兴趣。你知道，如果周围有一把吉他，我可以拿起来弹一些东西。但我想要变得更好。我想上一些课，把鼓打得更好。你会为你的孩子们弹吉他或者什么别的吗？我的意思是，我们有乐器。
at the house and I've played stuff, but they're kind of, we also have a drum set. set. And it seems like they're more interested in the drums at the stage. Yeah. That tracks. Yeah. It's kind of easy to bang around. And this will make no sense if you haven't seen it. But you can see me play drums on my Netflix special. I'm happy to be here. Okay. Yeah. So that's for the listeners. If they would like to see me play the drums. I'm writing it down. I do our social media tag. So I'm going to put a little swipe up to that. Okay. Our next question is, what's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved? Ah. There's so many places, and Stephanie makes fun of me because I've toured, I mean, I've been doing stand-up almost 30 years, and I go around the world, I go to small towns,
在家的时候我弹过一些，但他们，我们还有一个架子鼓。然后在这个阶段，他们似乎对架子鼓更感兴趣。对。这很合情合理。对。那种东西随便敲敲挺容易的。如果你没看过的话，这可能听不明白。但你可以在我的网飞（Netflix）特辑里看到我打鼓。我很高兴能来到这里。好的。对。所以那是给听众们的。如果他们想看我打鼓的话。我把它记下来。我做我们的社交媒体标签。所以我要在上面加一个小箭头。好的。我们的下一个问题是，你去过哪个让你绝对爱不释手的地方？啊。地方太多了，斯蒂芬妮（Stephanie）老拿我开玩笑，因为我巡演过，我的意思是，我做单口喜剧快30年了，我走遍世界各地，我去过小镇，
college towns, big cities, everywhere. And there is. not a place that I don't love. I mean, I really, where are you from? I was born in Louisiana, but my family's from Louisiana and Texas. Oh, okay. Okay. Yeah, I hear it. But I grew up in Indonesia, so it's weird. It is weird. I know. Yes. But you're like, it is weird. It is. I confirm. Yes. I mean, just the other day, Oklahoma came up and I was like, oh, I love Tulsa. And Stephanie was like, what? And I was like, I do. And then Indiana, It's like I love Bloomington. There are so many places that I love, and I do not write any state off or little town because of anything.
大学城，大城市，到处都是。而且没有一个地方是我不喜欢的。我是说，真的，你是哪儿人？我出生在路易斯安那州，但我家人来自路易斯安那州和得克萨斯州。哦，好吧。好吧。对，我听得出来。但我是在印度尼西亚长大的，所以这挺奇怪的。确实挺奇怪。我知道。是的。但你会觉得，这很奇怪。是的。我证实。对。我是说，就在前几天，说到了俄克拉荷马州，我就说，哦，我喜欢塔尔萨。斯蒂芬妮就问，什么？我说，我真的喜欢。还有印第安纳州，就像我喜欢布卢明顿。有太多我喜欢的地方了，我不会因为任何原因就把哪个州或小镇一笔勾销。
Because there are – I'm originally from Mississippi. Mm-hmm. And – 501? 601. 601. Yeah. I was close.
因为有——我原本来自密西西比州。嗯哼。而且——501？601。601。对。我猜得挺近。
Yeah, you were. My aunt was in Mississippi, and my dad always called her 601. That's it. I'm a 601er. But I remember leaving, I was in Jackson, getting some award from the governor. And I was with my stepfather and my brother, and we were walking out of this restaurant. And this guy ran out of the restaurant, chases me down. And he thanks me for representing Mississippi in a positive way.
对，确实挺近。我阿姨在密西西比，我爸爸总是叫她601。就是这样。我是个601人。但我记得离开的时候，我在杰克逊，从州长那里领奖。我和我继父还有我弟弟在一起，我们正从一家餐馆走出来。然后有个家伙从餐馆里跑出来，一路追着我。他感谢我以积极的方式代表了密西西比。
And he said, we're not all like what people think. He was like, and he was just, he was just so. genuinely thankful and it was such a reminder that there are incredible people everywhere and regardless of who's representing your city, state, country, there are people that are just tremendous and make these cities cool and great in the little pockets and the towns that you think, oh, there's nothing going on here. And so I just, I really do have such an appreciation for so many places. And I do love Tulsa and Bloomington.
他说，我们并不都像人们想象的那样。他说，而且他真的是——发自内心地感谢，这真是一个提醒，无论谁代表你的城市、州或国家，到处都有不可思议的人，都有那些了不起的人，他们在各个角落、在那些你觉得“哦，这里什么都没有”的小镇里，让这些城市变得酷炫而伟大。所以我真的对很多地方充满感激。我确实很喜欢塔尔萨和布卢明顿。
And Iowa City, I love so many places. Do you do the same? Because wherever we go, my husband teases me about this. It doesn't matter where we go, I immediately am like on Redfin. I'm like, okay, how do people live here? Where do they live? What do their homes look like? I'm like so curious.
还有爱荷华城，我喜欢太多地方了。你们也这样吗？因为无论我们走到哪里，我丈夫都会拿这个取笑我。不管我们去哪里，我马上就会上红芬（Redfin）网站。我就想，好吧，人们是怎么在这里生活的？他们住在哪里？他们的房子长什么样？我太好奇了。
Yeah. And then you find those towns where you can get like an eight-bedroom house. I know. It's like what on earth? Have like. barn and, yeah, two barns, yeah, you know. I also, I'm a vegan person, which shifted after I got sick. I've changed my diet, and that's part of the fun of touring for me as well, is I have this
对。然后你会发现那些可以买到八居室房子的城镇。我知道。这简直不可思议。还带个——谷仓，对，两个谷仓，对，你知道的。还有，我是个素食主义者，这在我生病后改变了。我改变了饮食习惯，这也是对我来说巡演的乐趣之一，我有一个
app called Happy Cow and you just put in wherever you are. And it tells you the nearest vegan restaurants. Really? Oh, my gosh. And when people are like, well, I live in this place and I can't, I'm like, no, no, no, I have Happy Cow. And I, because it gives you vegan options, and then if there aren't any, and then it goes to vegetarian.
叫“快乐奶牛”（Happy Cow）的应用程序，你只需输入你所在的位置。它就会告诉你最近的素食餐厅。真的吗？噢，天哪。当人们说，嗯，我住在这个地方，我没法……我就会说，不，不，不，我有“快乐奶牛”。而且我，因为它会为你提供素食选择，如果没有的话，它就会推荐素食主义选项。
And so it kind of goes down the, down the line. Yeah. And so I can always find something somewhere. Happy cow, folks. Happy cow. You heard it here. But I love, it makes touring so fun for me to find new vegan restaurants and options. Yeah.
所以它基本上是按顺序来的。对。所以我总能在某个地方找到吃的。快乐奶牛，各位。快乐奶牛。你们在这儿听说的。但我喜欢，它让我的巡演变得非常有趣，能找到新的素食餐厅和选择。对。
That leads into our next question. It does? Wow. Number five. Oh, no, it doesn't. Number four. Never mind. doesn't hold that thought. Well, can't we do five and then do four? No. Oh, I'm kidding. No, we could. Do we
这就引出了我们的下一个问题。是吗？哇。第五个。哦，不对，不是。第四个。算了。别介意。保留这个想法。那个，我们不能先做第五个再做第四个吗？不行。哦，我开玩笑呢。不，我们可以。我们要
want to do that? Do we want to shake it up? Shake it up. All right. Question number five, what's your favorite midnight snack? Well, I'm rarely awake at midnight. Yeah, I know. This could be your favorite, like, I'm watching TV snack, too. Your favorite, Indulgence. Well, that's what I was going to say is, I mean, it's not a crazy indulgence, but our son, and I'm not saying this because I'm sitting here with you, too. But our sons, and I understand friends is not the office, but our sons got really into friends when we were on vacation. We would let them watch it if we were in a hotel room. And then it, for some reason, after this last summer, transferred over to our house where, every night we watch friends and have popcorn. And it's a whole family situation of watching an episode of friends before bed. And we're at season five. And after we finish friends, we're going to the office. And we're going to watch the entire run of the office. And that's because their grandfather is into the office. And he's who started showing them the office when
这么做吗？我们要改变一下吗？改变一下。好的。第五个问题，你最喜欢的午夜小吃是什么？嗯，我很少在半夜醒着。对，我知道。这也可以是你最喜欢的，比如，看电视时吃的小吃。你最喜欢的，放纵一下。好吧，我本来想说的是，我的意思是，这算不上什么疯狂的放纵，但我们的儿子——我这么说可不是因为我也正跟你坐在一起。但是我们的儿子——我明白《老友记》不是《办公室》，不过我们的儿子们在度假时迷上了《老友记》。如果我们在酒店房间里，我们会让他们看。然后，出于某种原因，在今年夏天过去之后，这种习惯转移到了我们家里，每天晚上我们都一边看《老友记》一边吃爆米花。这就成了全家人在睡觉前一起看一集《老友记》的固定节目。我们已经看到第五季了。等我们看完《老友记》，我们就要去看《办公室》。我们要把《办公室》整部剧都刷一遍。那是因为他们的祖父很喜欢《办公室》。是他最先带他们看《办公室》的，
they were four. And so now that they're watching, you know, iconic sitcoms, the offices are next in line to plow through. If you need Pam and Angela to wish them a happy birthday, we will. We will make a video. That would be amazing. Yes. All right. Number four. What do you like to do on the weekends? I mean, because my career is so all over the place of recording my podcast of recording my podcast and doing shows and acting and whatever. A weekend is kind of a weekday. It doesn't. What is the weekend? As the Dowager says. Yes. Downton Abbey. Anyone? Anyone? No. No. What is the weekend? Okay, never mind. Forget it. She's saying it for a different reason, though. She's saying it because she lives a life
当时他们才四岁。所以现在他们既然在看那些标志性的情景喜剧，《办公室》就是下一个排队要刷完的剧。如果你需要帕姆和安吉拉祝他们生日快乐，我们可以。我们可以录个视频。那太棒了。好的。第四个。你喜欢在周末做什么？我是说，因为我的职业生涯太分散了，要录播客、录播客、做演出、演戏以及各种事情。周末对平时的我来说差不多就是工作日。这没什么。什么是周末？正如唐顿庄园老太君所说。是的。唐顿庄园。有人知道吗？有人吗？没有。没有。什么是周末？好吧，算了。忘了吧。不过她说这话有别的原因。她说这话是因为她过着
of leisure. Right. She doesn't know what the weekend is. It's true. This is the opposite. This is the opposite of that. Yeah. True. Well, yeah. And I have my relationship. and children, and then I'm just a person alive on the planet, too, and so I have my own things I want to do. So I am busy, but because I'm not on tour and because I'm not filming right now, my favorite thing to do is walk around the house saying, I'm a normal person, just having a normal day, just doing normal things. I'm a normal person. It's the most uncatchy song, but I love being home, just like going to baseball and basketball, perhaps, and then having a snack and shuffling around the house.
闲适的生活。没错。她不知道什么是周末。确实如此。这完全相反。这与那正好相反。对。没错。而且我有我的感情生活和孩子，然后我也是个活在这个世界上的普通人，所以我有我想做的事。所以我是很忙，但因为我没有在巡演，而且我现在也没有在拍戏，我最喜欢做的事就是在房子里走来走去，嘴里念叨着：“我是一个普通人，过着普通的一天，做着普通的事。我是一个普通人。”这歌听起来真不顺口，但我就是喜欢待在家里，比如去看看棒球和篮球比赛，然后吃点零食，在屋里晃悠。
And I just, I am in heaven. Yeah. And then I just start singing the uncatchy song of, I'm a normal person, live in a normal life, do a normal thing. Like laundry. Yeah. And I love it. So it's weekends or weekdays.
然后我就开始哼唱那首不顺口的歌：我是一个普通人，过着普通的生活，做着普通的事。比如洗衣服。对。我太喜欢了。所以不管是周末还是工作日。
But when I'm not like back to back with things, I have to do. And then this Zoom is over and then I have to do this interview and then I have to go And then I have to leave for the airport. And I, like, when it's like that, and I'm really trying to step away from that chaos. That pace is hard to keep up. It's really hard to keep up. And yet I find sometimes we set boundaries and we're not going to get sucked into it. And then we do.
但如果我没有连轴转的事情要应付，我得做这个。然后这个Zoom会议结束了，接着我得做这个采访，然后我得去——然后我得出发去机场。像这样的时候，我真的在努力摆脱那种混乱。那种节奏很难保持。真的很难保持。然而我发现有时我们设立了界限，本打算不被卷入其中。但结果我们还是卷进去了。
And then we're like, gosh, how did we get sucked in? Well, because you have weak boundaries. That's how it happened. Because I'm a normal person. I'm at home doing normal things because I'm normal and I'm loving my life. Oh, Tigg, we love you. And I, you. Thank you for coming and talking with us.
然后我们就想，天哪，我们是怎么被卷进去的？噢，因为你的界限感太弱了。事情就是这样发生的。因为我是一个普通人。我在家里做着普通的事，因为我很普通，而且我热爱我的生活。哦，蒂格，我们爱你。我也爱你们。谢谢你们来跟我们聊天。
Thank you for having me. Yes. The one thing we didn't talk about is your handsome podcasts. That's what I was about to say. We love. Okay. Well, you're both yelling at me. No, but we do. I mean, Cassie is wearing a baseball hat right now that says, little cowboy.
谢谢你们邀请我。对。我们有一件没聊的事，就是你们那个超赞的播客。我正想说呢。我们非常喜欢。好吧，你们俩都在对我大喊大叫。没有，但我们真的很喜欢。我是说，卡西现在戴着一顶棒球帽，上面写着“小牛仔”。
Uh-huh. Yes. It's a silly show. So you have Fortune, who's so funny. And May. I met Fortune. We were both on a panel for that show to tell us. the truth. And she was so incredibly funny. And I just, I love her on the Insta. I keep up with
嗯哼。是的。这是一个搞笑的节目。所以你们有福彻（Fortune），她太搞笑了。还有梅（May）。我见过福彻。我们俩一起参加那个节目的小组讨论，节目叫《说出真相》。她真的超级搞笑。我太喜欢她在社交软件上的动态了。我一直在那里关注
her there. Same. Silly, silly, silly. And part of... I just love listening to you guys chat. Well, thank you. It's kind of like what I was saying before, how I was dealing with serious things all the time and trying to be helpful and supportive. And it almost became, as they say, a brand. which is great and fine. But I was also like, I want to just be stupid with some comedian pals. Yeah. And so that's what sparked handsome. And, you know, we're not a political show.
她。我也是。太搞笑、太搞笑、太搞笑了。其中一部分……我就是喜欢听你们聊天。哦，谢谢。这有点像我之前说的，我如何一直在处理严肃的事情，试图提供帮助和支持。它几乎变成了一种，正如他们所说的，人设（品牌）。这挺好的，也没问题。但我也在想，我想和一些喜剧演员朋友一起犯傻。对。所以这就是激发《Handsome》播客灵感的原因，而且，我们不是一个政治节目。
We're not, I mean, sometimes we have genuine questions that come in from people. And you guys should submit a question as well. Oh, yeah. We'll do that. I'll submit a question. Yeah, please do. You know, some, it just really runs the gamut of the questions that we get from people. And mostly we spin it into nonsense, but sometimes, you know, we'll ride an authentic, genuine wave of a response.
我们不是，我是说，有时我们会收到人们发来的真实问题。你们也应该提个问题。哦，好啊。我们会这么做的。我会提个问题。对，请一定要提。你知道的，有些，我们收到的问题真的是五花八门。大部分时候我们把它胡扯成无厘头的话题，但有时，你知道的，我们会顺着一个真实、真诚的回答继续聊下去。
Yeah, we should tell everyone listening, when you go check it out, because it's fantastic, you guys have banter at the top, and then you have a question that has been sent in by someone, Jimmy Fallon, or. you know, whatever. There's people from all over that send in questions. And then you guys all just kind of riff on what your answer would be to that. And it's really, really fun. And then we play the answer at the end. At the end. Because the guest also answers their own question. Yeah. But it's very free form chat. Yeah. Yeah. So. By three hilarious people. Oh, well, thank you. Yes. Who all have, one of the benefits is you guys all have very. distinctive voices. It's very easy to tell who's talking. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. And we're also, May is in their 30s, fortunes in her 40s. I'm in my 50s. I have kids. I mean, I'm married with kids.
对，我们应该告诉所有听众，当你们去收听时——因为这个节目太棒了——你们开头会有一段闲聊，然后是一个听众发来的问题，比如吉米·法伦（Jimmy Fallon），或者别的什么人。世界各地的人都会发来问题。然后你们所有人就会针对这个问题即兴发挥，聊聊你们会有什么答案。这真的非常非常有趣。然后我们在最后播放那个答案。在最后。因为嘉宾也会回答他们自己的问题。对。但这完全是自由形式的闲聊。对。对。所以。由三个超级搞笑的人主持。哦，谢谢。是的。他们都有一个共同点，就是你们每个人都有非常鲜明的嗓音。非常容易听出来是谁在说话。对。对。对。而且我们还，梅30多岁，福彻40多岁。我50多岁。我有孩子。我是说，我已婚有孩子。
Fortune's married. May is single and really getting out there mingling. Yeah. And there's a lot of differences and cultural references that one of you will know and the other won't. And Cassie was mentioning that before you got here, that she liked that the three different voices were in different sort of places in their lives. Yes. Oh, TIG, one more thing before we go. Will you please tell us about the documentary you produced? I produced a documentary called Come See Me in the Good Light. And it is about my dear friend, Andrea Gibson, of 25 years, the poet laureate of the state of Colorado, who has state.
福彻已婚。梅是单身，而且真的经常出门社交。对。这里有很多差异和文化参考，你们中一个人会知道，另一个人则不知道。卡西在你来之前就提到过这一点，她喜欢这三种不同的声音处于生活中的不同阶段。是的。哦，蒂格，在我们离开之前还有一件事。你能跟我们讲讲你制作的那部纪录片吗？我制作了一部名为《来看看洒满阳光的我》（Come See Me in the Good Light）的纪录片。讲的是我25年的挚友安德烈娅·吉布森（Andrea Gibson），科罗拉多州的桂冠诗人，她患有
for ovarian cancer, and this film is so beautiful. It went to Sundance this year. And we all rented an Airbnb. It's produced by, you know, Glennon Doyle, Abby Wombach, Sarah Borellis, Brandy Carlis, Brandy Carlis. Everybody's just massive Andrea Gibson fans. This person is, it's poetry that is so accessible that will inspire you and destroy you and make you, it'll just blow your mind. Just such a talent. Anyway, we all go to Sundance. Andrea's not doing great. And we just went to the screenings, standing ovations.
卵巢癌，这部电影太美了。它今年去了圣丹斯电影节。我们都租了一个爱彼迎（Airbnb）。制片人有，你知道的，格伦农·多尔（Glennon Doyle）、艾比·翁巴赫（Abby Wombach）、莎拉·鲍雷利斯（Sarah Borellis）、布兰迪·卡莉丝（Brandi Carlile）、布兰迪·卡莉丝。每个人都是安德烈娅·吉布森的超级粉丝。这个人，她的诗歌非常平易近人，能激励你、摧毁你，让你，这绝对会让你大开眼界。真是太有才华了。不管怎样，我们都去了圣丹斯。安德烈娅状况不是很好。我们只是去看了放映，全场起立鼓掌。
You hear people sobbing through the screenings. The funny parts, it's like it could be a Will Ferrell movie. People are laughing so hard. And we were like, wow, this screened really well. But we didn't have the typical Sundance experience because we would go back to our Airbnb that we all were staying in and have tea, sit by the fire, hang out with Andrea and their partner Meg, who is also a poet in the film as well. And we went to the screenings. We weren't going to the parties and the events. And then we leave.
你能听到人们在放映过程中泣不成声。搞笑的部分，简直就像是一部威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）的电影。大家笑得前仰后合。我们当时想，哇，这部电影放映效果真好。但我们并没有经历典型的圣丹斯体验，因为我们会回到我们所有人住在一起的爱彼迎，喝茶，坐在火炉旁，和安德烈娅以及她们的伴侣梅（Meg）一起闲逛，梅也是电影中的一位诗人。我们去了放映会。我们没有去参加派对和活动。然后我们就离开了。
And we're just like, this went so well. It screened so well. And then I get home to Toronto. My phone is exploding. Can you get on a call? Hey, you know, and Meg called me directly as well, Andrea's partner. And I immediately was like, oh, God, this is bad. And I call Stephanie, and I'm like, I'm so scared to return this call.
我们就在想，这次太顺利了。放映效果太棒了。然后我回到多伦多。我的电话炸了。你能接个电话吗？嘿，你知道的，安德烈娅的伴侣梅也直接给我打电话了。我立刻就想，哦天哪，这不妙。我给斯蒂芬妮打电话，我说，我太害怕回这个电话了。
So I mean, like, just call back. And I'm like on the edge of like losing my mind. I'm so scared to return this call. And I call Meg answers the phone. And Meg and Andrea are like, did you hear the news? And I was like, what? We won the Sundance Festival. Oh my gosh.
我是说，快回电话吧。我简直快要崩溃了。我太害怕回这个电话了。我给梅打电话，梅接了电话。梅和安德烈娅说，你听到消息了吗？我说，什么？我们赢了圣丹斯电影节。噢，天哪。
Not just in documentaries. It won the top award of Sundance this year. Oh my gosh. I then was in tears of joy. I was so confused because we didn't get a vibe. of how the movie was going. Yeah, because you were in your little sanctuary away. Snuggle down.
不仅在纪录片类别。它获得了今年圣丹斯电影节的最高奖项。噢，天哪。我当时激动得喜极而泣。我太困惑了，因为我们根本不知道电影反响会怎么样。对，因为你们待在你们的小避难所里。躲得舒舒服服的。
We were just like having snuggle down. And that was all we were doing. And our director who did the documentary Pamela, I don't know if you saw that of Pamela Anderson. He did the Serena Williams doc, the Dr. Ruth doc. But he was like, movies like ours do not win Sundance. And so, and it's sold and it'll be coming out later this year. But it's such a beautiful film.
我们当时只是在舒舒服服地呆着。我们的导演帕梅拉（Pamela）拍过那部帕梅拉·安德森的纪录片，我还不知道你们看过没有。他还拍过塞雷娜·威廉姆斯（Serena Williams）的纪录片、Dr. Ruth的纪录片。但他说过，像我们这样的电影是不会赢得圣丹斯的。所以，而且它已经被买下了，今年晚些时候就会上映。但这真的是一部非常美丽的电影。
Oh, I can't wait to see it. It screened at the Boulder Film Festival, and it just won that festival as well. Wow. Last night, we just got the news that it won that as well. So it's really, really, you walk out the door and you want to go live your life like you've never lived it before. It's incredible. Wow. Amazing.
哦，我等不及要看了。它在博尔德电影节（Boulder Film Festival）放映了，并且也赢得了那个电影节的奖项。哇。就在昨晚，我们刚刚得知它也赢得了那个奖。所以真的是，你走出家门，就会想以从未有过的方式去生活。这太不可思议了。哇。太棒了。
Anyway, thank you for having me. Thank you so much, Tig, for being here and just being you. We just, we're so happy to have this time with you. Same. And I'm glad you're doing well. And I hope you're doing well. I am. Good.
不管怎样，谢谢你们邀请我。非常感谢蒂格来到这里，做真实的自己。我们真的，很高兴能有时间和聊天。我也是。我很高兴你一切都好。希望你也一切都好。我很好。太好了。
Thanks. Yeah. Right. Now we're going to end in a whisper. I guess we should bring it back here. Okay. For sure. Just feels like we should.
谢谢。对。现在我们要以耳语结束。我想我们应该回到这里来。好的。肯定的。感觉我们就应该这样做。
Yeah. Okay. All right. Bye. Thanks. Thank you. Well, a big thank you to TIG Nataro for coming in the studio to chat with us. And thank you to everyone who wrote in today such great questions for TIG.
对。好的。好的。再见。谢谢。非常感谢蒂格·纳塔罗（Tig Notaro）来到工作室和我们聊天。也谢谢今天写信给蒂格、提出这么棒的问题的每一个人。
And you can find out more about TIG and her schedule of shows on her website, TIGNation.com, and be sure to check out her comedy special Hello Again on Prime Video. It's so funny. So funny. There's also her podcast, Handsome and, of course, Star Trek Starfleet Academy. And since we recorded this interview, TIG's friend and poet Andrea Gibson, very sadly, passed away over the summer. And this episode was recorded back in March. Yes.
你可以在蒂格的网站TIGNation.com上了解更多关于她以及她的演出日程的信息，千万别忘了去Prime Video观看她的喜剧特辑《再见你好》（Hello Again）。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。还有她的播客《Handsome》，当然，还有《星际迷航：星际舰队学院》（Star Trek Starfleet Academy）。自从我们录制完这次采访后，蒂格的朋友、诗人安德烈娅·吉布森非常不幸地在今年夏天去世了。这集节目是在3月份录制的。是的。
And we can all honor and celebrate Andrea's story in the beautiful. beautiful documentary, come see me in the Good Light, coming to Apple Plus on November 14th. Yes, and I'll be sure and share it in our stories. Thanks again, everyone, for writing in. Thank you, TIG, and we will see you all next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
我们都可以通过将于11月14日在Apple Plus上映的美丽纪录片《来看看洒满阳光的我》来缅怀和庆祝安德烈娅的故事。是的，我一定会把它分享到我们的动态里。再次感谢大家的来信。谢谢蒂格，我们下周见。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由奥德赛（Audyssey）呈现，由珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubbicoe）。奥德赛的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Ruppertree》。谢谢。这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。